[Musique]
et voilà c'est parti pour un nouveau
stream alors merci d'être là avec avec
moi ce soir il ya eu quelques
difficultés dimanche dernier on n'a pas
su parler de l'article parce qu'en fait
j'avais pas de connexion je sais pas si
c'est à cause de la tempête qui a pas eu
de réseau mais j'avais le signal rouge
sur le modèle wifi et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a reporté la lecture de cet
article sur le décrochage scolaire à
aujourd'hui et donc si si vous êtes ou
si tu es nouveau sur sur ce stream en
fait l'idée c'est que toutes les
semaines sur la sociaux tech on lit
ensemble un article de sciences sociales
alors deux préférence un article
scientifique
parfois c'est pas vraiment des sciences
sociales pur pur et dur aujourd'hui ça
l'est plus tôt même si c'est un article
est issu de la revue française de
pédagogie et l'idée de cette lecture
d'articles bon bah c'est déjà de
découvrir ensemble
l'actualité finalement scientifique des
sciences sociales
moi je n'aurai pas le temps de faire des
vidéos vraiment monté où j'explique où
je vais je réalise un résumé de ses
articles là et donc c'est pour ça déjà
que je fais ça en direct avec vous avec
toi mais aussi ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est que on lit ces
articles pour toi comme moi
s'initier vraiment à la lecture des
sciences sociales enfin s'initier ou pas
mais je vais dire vraiment ces ensembles
de voir des méthodologies de recherche
essayer de comprendre finalement comment
est ce qu'on fait des recherches de
sciences sociales parce que
personnellement je suis prof de sciences
sociales au secondaire et donc c'est
super important pour moi de me tenir au
courant des méthodes mais aussi des
contenus pour pouvoir en discuter
parfois avec les élèves quoi donc ça
c'est un petit peu l'objet de la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui alors toutes les semaines
je mets je soumets une sélection de
trois articles au vote donc ça c'est sur
l'onglet communauté de la société que tu
peux voter pour l'article que tu
préfères le la publication pour le
prochain article de dimanche va être
programmé je crois que les programmes
est pour aujourd'hui soir ou demain donc
demain tu peux voter pour l'article que
tu préfères ça c'est une autre chose
et alors il ya aussi d'autres stream sur
la sociaux tech
le premier stream que je vais faire ce
sera aujourd'hui soir après celui ci ça
va être la présentation d'un programme
d'un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle française on découvre le
programme ensemble aujourd'hui voilà
c'est eric zemmour d'habitude je joue
aussi un jeu juste après et on essaie
d'appliquer le programme du candidat
alors je suis désolé mais eric zemmour a
été condamné pour certaine provocation à
la haine eric zemmour et xénophobes
antisémites islamophobes
il vise carrément les individus sains il
n'est par exemple il ne contrairement à
marine le pen qui par exemple la visée
l'immigration en général lui vise
vraiment des individus qu'il considère
comme des ennemis de la nation il se
déclare aussi contre les droits de
l'homme et donc moi je veux bien en
parler mais je ne vais pas jouer avec un
programme comme celui-là voilà ça c'est
mes convictions en moi on peut ne pas
être d'accord on peut être d'accord peu
importe c'est ma chaîne je fais ce que
je veux et moi j'ai pas envie de jouer
avec les idées d'ideye d'eric zemmour
donc on va regarder son programme mais
on va pas jouer au jeu cette fois-ci
quoi donc ça c'est une chose est alors
demain demain à 20h30 mais il se peut
que ça soit un peu plus tard parce que
demain j'ai d'autres choses à faire
avant là il ya une émission politique
dans laquelle il ya différentes
rubriques où on va présenter alors on va
présenter le programme d'eric zemmour
parce que c'est un petit peu le candidat
auquel on s'intéresse cette semaine je
parle aussi des sondages des parrainages
il ya aussi une revue de presse de
l'actualité de la semaine écoulée et
alors il ya un dossier on parle d'un
thème précis par rapport à la campagne
et demain on va parler un petit peu des
sondages est ce que les sondages sont
fiables est ce que les sondages son
influence le vote on va un petit peu
discuter de tout ça il y aura bien sûr
aussi toute une à tout un moment
consacré à vos questions avec une faq
doxa n'hésite pas à être en direct et on
pourra répondre à toutes les questions
qu'on se pose sur cette présidentielle
alors
même avis bas super
bienvenue romain vie comme
je pense que c'est la première fois que
je vois ton pseudo sur sur le chat doko
ben voilà on se rejoint mais bon moi je
suis pour parler des idées si les
candidats la prison si l on peut en
parler mais je vais pas commencer à
dérouler le tapis rouge est comment dire
et à jouer surtout à faire des choses un
peu légère avec des idées qui sont quand
même relativement grave je pense voilà
ça c'est une parenthèse alors on en
vient à notre article aujourd'hui je
change de fenêtres popov alors cet
article vous pouvez le retrouver sur
kairn kern c'est une plate forme de
différents éditeurs ou vous allez
retrouver des ouvrages de sciences
sociales mais aussi des articles
scientifiques et des revues
scientifiques de sciences sociales mais
aussi d'autres d'autres matières alors
cet article s'il n'est pas en
consultation libre si vous voulez le le
consulter je pense qu'il faut payer un
c3 4,5 euros ça dépend un petit peu des
éditeurs mais maintenant si tu es
lecteurs ou si tu es étudiant dans une
université qui a sans doute accès à tous
ces outils fanon pas que tu as sans
doute c'est que tu as accès à tous ces
outils donc ça y'a pas de soucis donc ce
que je vais faire aussi s'est passé très
très vite pour éviter d'avoir vraiment
une lecture complète de l'article parce
que sinon je pense qu'au niveau des
droits des ayants droit ça posera
problème donc ça c'est une première
chose alors vous voyez que c'est la
revue française de pédagogie on nous
donne toutes les références un article
relativement récente 2021
donc j'essaie quand même d'avoir des
articles récents et les deux auteurs
c'est pierre-yves bernard et christophe
michaut voilà voyez toute reproduction
est interdite donc je vais pas je vais
pas le diffuser de manière complète et
vous pourrez pas le retrouver sur sûr
le descriptif souvent le descriptif je
mets des liens ici j'ai mis le lien mais
tu auras pas la version gratuite alors
il ya toujours un abstract au début qui
nous explique un petit peu le contenu de
l'article c'est surtout intéressant si
tu cherches des articles tu sais pas
encore exactement ce que tu dois lire
par rapport à ton ta recherche ou voilà
tu veux simplement te documenter sur un
élément ben tu peux juste lire
l'abstract et d'ailleurs je conseille
aux élèves qui débute en sciences
sociales peut-être des élèves qui ont 15
16 ans qui sont vraiment au début des
sciences sociales il faut pas hésiter à
aller sur des articles scientifiques
mais il se contente de lire cette
abstract parce que tu as déjà les
conclusions étaient déjà les éléments
essentiels et puis il ya des choses qui
sont difficiles à comprendre ben voilà
comme c'est pas très long on peut faire
un effort pour essayer de l'expliquer en
classe donc voilà prêt il faut pas aller
plus loin si on est débutant chaque
chose en son temps
alors bon on commence directement
l'article ici
avec cet article est consacré au
décrochage scolaire est d'emblée on nous
définit le décrochage scolaire quel
concept central de l'article comme des
ruptures de scolarité avant l'obtention
d'un diplôme terminal de l'enseignement
secondaire donc voilà le décrochage
scolaire ça concerne l'enseignement
secondaire ça ne concerne pas ça ne
concerne pas l'enseignement supérieur
c'est bien dit ici dans la définition
est déjà tu vois si tu as bien définis
tu es concept mais normalement tu as
déjà ton champ d'observation qui se
réduit parce que voilà qu'est ce que tu
veux aller observer tu sais que si tu
t'intéresses au décrochage scolaire il
faut se teinter être faut trouver des
élèves du secondaire tout simplement
quoi donc ça ça oriente déjà quand on
travaille de manière précise souvent les
élèves ne font pas l'effort on ne
précise pas assez dans les définitions
ou les définitions sont très équivoque
elles ont plusieurs significations et
donc finalement ben on s'embrouille et
on sait pas exactement ce qu'on vise
alors j'ai encore l'exemple ici avec la
cancel culture j'ai des élèves qui
reviennent souvent avec des idées de
travaux sur la cancel culture mais il ne
définissent pas bien là comme ça la
culture alors finalement il associe la
cancel culture à du harcèlement mais là
comme sale culture au départ c'est pas
du harcèlement ça peut être du
harcèlement mais c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus précis donc si tu ne
définit pas bien au départ battu risque
de s'égarer finalement de prendre des
poires pour des pommes c'est assez
problématique à ce moment là quand
on sait peu de choses sur ce qu'en
disent les premiers intéressés donc ça
c'est un peu la problématique de
l'arctique c'est vraiment de savoir
comment les élèves qui décrochent au
niveau de l'école le vivent et comment
il se représente un petit peu ces choses
là parce que dans le monde de la
recherche
apparemment selon ses auteurs ben voilà
c'est un c'est un aspect des choses qui
a été très peu étudié une bonne
problématique basse et souvent des
savoirs qui sont manquants et donc la
recherche vise à combler le vide et à
trouver des explications sur des choses
qu'on ne connaît pas ou qu'on ne sait
pas
alors ce désigne-t-il comme des
décrocheurs qu'est ce qui les a conduit
selon eux à interrompre leurs études ce
dès que se distille pardon de la
situation dans laquelle ils sont voilà
tout ça c'est un petit peu des questions
de départ je rappelle ici que finalement
une question de départ c'est une
question très générale qu'on se pose par
rapport à un objet d'étude qui le cas
échéant est un fait social après une
fois que tu auras bien travaillé dans sa
recherche tu vas reformuler la question
de départ en une question de recherche
qui est beaucoup plus précises parce que
voilà on voit qu'ici c'est des questions
très général
alors c'est assez intéressant j'étais
content quand le les personnes qui
suivent la sociétè coup peut être toi
vous avez voté pour cet article alors
petite anecdote le vote est toujours
possible pour céder à cette semaine ci
est en fait l'article il y avait un
autre article était proposée sur les
populismes de droite à thèmes plus
politiques eh bien il est passé devant
cet article 6 mais comme j'avais arrêté
le choix que j'avais commencé à
travailler sur cet article 6 voilà j'ai
quand même pas changé de d'articles mais
je suis assez content que ça se
suicident qu'ils soient sélectionnés
pour la raison suivante c'est que c'est
une enquête quantitative
nouveau conscience sociale cus et qui a
des méthodes qualitatives ou on va aller
vraiment en profondeur je te renvoie sur
la chaîne sur les premières vidéos la
première d'ailleurs que j'ai fait sur la
lecture d'un article de science sociale
qui était consacré au monde des sans
abri un article de thibaut benji qui
d'ailleurs nous a remerciés sur la
société que pour la qualité du stream
donc ça c'était sympa et bien là on
était vraiment dans une enquête
qualitatif parce que thibaut bezos dit
il a intégré le milieu des sans abri
pendant huit mois il s'est vraiment
intégré ben c'est le beau dans ce milieu
là est donc là tu vois on va être sur
des données très qualitatif tandis
qu'ici bam on interroge 3000 individus
là on est sur du quantitatif on va avoir
des données en quantité
bonjour qu'un 91,1 ou 91 ça dépend si tu
es si tu viens de france ou de belgique
ça tu peux le préciser dans le chat
comme ça on voit un petit peu
le public s'il est plutôt français ou
belge parce que l'achat de la société
qui marche très bien en france même si
ben voila moi si j'y enseigne en
belgique plus tôt et donc pour resituer
ce qu'on fait maths et français c'est
super donc si tu es nouveau sur sur la
chaîne super situé nouveau sur la chaîne
il ya aussi des émissions je fais des
stream je fais sur la politique français
ces élections présidentielles françaises
voilà a parfois on aime bien savoir ce
que les autres personnes pensent de
notre propre système politique et ben
voilà c'est un belge qui fait une
émission sur les élections
présidentielles françaises ça c'est
demain à 20h30 et donc ici ben voila tu
sais bien un requin
on est sur une observation quantitative
et c'est super intéressant de vulgariser
ça avec vous parce que parfois j'ai
l'impression je sais pas si c'est si
c'est votre cas mais parfois j'ai
l'impression que quand on parle de
sciences sociales le grand public
s'imagine que en fait on fait du débat
on discute on écrit les choses avec une
belle prose et finalement il ya rien de
grand chose de scientifique dans les
sciences sociales alors que quand tu lis
une enquête un article scientifique
basée sur des méthodes quantitatives
voilà après on est d'accord qu'on n'est
pas sur le même type de science que des
sciences naturelles mais ça reste un
processus scientifique totalement
objectif et qui peut être comment dire
toujours contrôlée par quelqu'un par la
suite ce que je dis souvent aux élèves
l'importance et qu'on puisse retracer
votre cheminement et que si on n'est pas
d'accord que la personne soit en mesure
d'aller ciblés dans votre travail ce
avec quoi elle n'est pas d'accord si on
n'est pas transparent sur sa
méthodologie et sur la méthode de
vérification des hypothèses mais à ce
moment là on n'est pas dans un processus
scientifique parce qu'il n'est pas
reproductible
oui c'est ça une science empirique donc
voilà on est en plein dedans et c'est ça
que j'aime dans cet article c'est que il
ya vraiment une partie empirique
vraiment conséquente
j'essaie de lire beaucoup d'articles de
deux options sociales et finalement
parfois tu te dis mais aller où l'empiré
quoi est donc ici c'est ça qui est
vraiment sympa dans cet article 6
alors donc ses 3000 individus étaient
invités à donner les motifs de leur
interruption d'études ou de formation et
on verra après comment le questionnaire
a été construit
le décrochage scolaire est fréquemment
vécu comme la continuité d'une
expérience scolaire négative plutôt que
comme une rupture accidentelle de
parcours et ça je trouvais déjà
intéressant cette affirmation qui est
sans doute issue
de la revue de la littérature des
lectures des auteurs c'est que
c'est vrai que on pense souvent voile
élèves décrochent parce qu'il y à une
cause unique parce qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose et comme je dis souvent
aux élèves ben voilà le sociologue
arriver dit mais c'est plus compliqué
que ça et donc ici c'est plus compliqué
que ça et on voit directement dans cette
introduction que le décrochage scolaire
s'inscrit dans la durée
je trouvais déjà ça intéressant comme
comme affirmation
ces expériences sont variables en
fonction du genre du milieu social
d'origine et du parcours scolaire et
elles ont un effet sur les perspectives
de raccrochage et sur l'insertion
professionnelle donc là c'est voilà
c'est la sociologie pur on va regarder
comment les différentes appartenances
vont jouer mais aussi il ya un côté
pratique et moi en tant qu'enseignant je
trouve ça intéressant d'avoir lu cet
article parce que ça donne aussi des
pistes sur comment prévenir le
décrochage scolaire comment peut- être
identifié le décrochage scolaire est
peut-être comment le traiter même si
personnellement dans ma pratique c'est
plus compliqué de voilà de tout seul à
partir d'un cours de lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire ou le favoriser le
raccrochage scolaire mais ça permet
quand même avoir une bonne vision
alors le décrochage scolaire envoie des
situations objectivables et ça c'est
super important comme tu le disais
requins ben voilà il faut aller dans
l'empiré il faut observer ça dans la
réalité et si on n'a pas de critères
objectivables si on n'a pas d'éléments à
regarder à observer comment veux tu as
vraiment mesurer le phénomène et le
traité quoi c'est ce que je dis souvent
aux élèves
la une des étapes importantes d'une
recherche de sciences sociales ses de
transformer des concepts qui sont
parfois très abstrait en indicateurs et
on fait ça dans notre vie de tous les
jours finalement quand tu es dans une
relation amoureuse ou pas quand tu es
dans une relation amoureuse comme en
atteste que tu sais que la personne est
en phase avec tes sentiments à toi mais
ça va être tout des petites choses que
tu peux observer des regards
le fait qu'on envoie des textos
ou des snap plus régulièrement le fait
voilà deux peut-être offrir un cadeau
comme ça de manière gratuite le fait
simplement de voir le côté positif des
choses chaque fois que tu as le moral un
petit peu en berne donc c'est tout et
finalement des éléments
objectivables des éléments observable
qui vont te permettre de savoir que tu
es bien dans la relation amoureuse et ta
relation se porte bien ou pas quoi et
donc ici c'est exactement ça qu'on fait
en sciences sociales mais de manière
beaucoup plus précise de manière
beaucoup plus rigoureuse on va essayer
de trouver des indicateurs qui vont
permettre de bien objectiver les
situations encore une fois et que ce
soit comment dire qu'on soit dans des
process
qui
sont réfutable dans le sens où si on
n'est pas d'accord avec les conclusions
on peut revenir voir sur les revenir
discuter sur table méthodologie voir les
indicateurs que tu avais choisi
peut-être que c'était des mauvais choix
peut-être que ta façon d'observer les
indicateurs n'étaient pas les bons ou
peut-être que voilà c'était simplement
parfait avec la personne qui conteste
les conclusions et de mon vin et modes
de mauvaise foi et donc à ce moment là
ça va être discutée difficile de
discuter science avec cette personne là
quoi en tout cas voilà sur des bases
rationnelles donc c'est super important
d'arriver sur des choses objectivables
un parcours constitue où je crois que
j'ai perdu le fil
voilà le décrochage scolaire peut ainsi
être mesuré et analysé à partir de
facteurs met en évidence sa variabilité
sur les milieux sociaux le jour les
acquis scolaires un parcours constitue
une succession d'étapes d'événements de
choix de positions occupées et s'inscrit
toujours dans un contexte socio
historique donnée évidemment il ya tout
un contexte dans lequel tu as scolarité
de décrocheurs scolaires
s'intègrent et donc on peut jamais faire
abstraction du contexte moi ça m'a fait
toujours rire j'ai une expérience dans
le privé et avait toujours des
supérieurs hiérarchiques qui te disais
ouais les problèmes il faut les laisser
chez toi et tout ça mais comment est-ce
possible ton action elles s'inscrivent
toujours dans un contexte dans un
contexte personnel et puis dans un
contexte collectif et puis dans un
contexte social
qui est déterminé donc
voilà
l'expérience scolaire en tant que
dimension subjective du parcours
scolaire c'est vraiment ça qui intéresse
quelques heures de cet article c'est la
dimension subjective du parcours
scolaire comment le sujet vit-il son
parcours scolaire et là on touche aussi
à une base
je viens sur ton commentaire tout de
suite requins mais je termine mon idée
on arrive sur quelque chose parfois que
les une erreur quand que l'on fait
cesser de confondre un objet d'étude et
un sujet d'étude un sujet d'étude c'est
un individu qui a une réflexion
subjective avec des réalités subjectif
qui peuvent être produites mais ce sont
des réalités parfois les élèves me
disent oui mais bon ça c'est ce que les
personnes pensent c'est pas vraiment
réel mais si c'est réel c'est dépenser
qui sont réelles donc ça ce sont des
réalités subjective et la dimension
subjective est un objet d'étude comme
l'est comme le sont des dimensions
objectifs qui sont liées à un objet la
méritocratie n'est pas présente dans
l'école pourquoi retrouve-t-on des
valeurs similaires
des classes sup
je suppose que tu fais référence à
bourdieu simplement voilà que la culture
scolaire est une culture bourgeoise
et que donc voila tu es issu d'un milieu
bourgeois tu aura plus de facilités
parce que peut-être que tes parents
pratiquer des langues étrangères parce
que tes parents avaient des bouquins
chez eux parce que tes parents t'ont
menée en voyage parce que tes parents
l'emmenaient faire des activités
culturelles et que tu sortais de chez
toi et donc quand tu arrives dans un
milieu scolaire tu es déjà un petit peu
initiés à tout ça ne fût ce que par le
langage
voilà j'avais fait une analyse assez
confiant synthèse c'est complète de
des positions de bourdieu par rapport à
ça et en fait
quand on parle d'héritage culturel parce
que c'est ça qu'il faut parler
d'héritage culturel privé ou de familial
que tu emmènes finalement l'école et qui
te donne un avantage par rapport à
l'école il ya cinq dimensions ça la
première dimension ça va être de
l'information sur le système scolaire en
tant que tel des individus des
catégories sociales ne comprennent pas
comment fonctionne l'école avec tout
c'est tous ces choix toutes ces
orientations
ou le connaissent de manière très
maladroite le système scolaire c'est à
dire que par exemple tu vas
comment dire savoir qu'il ya différentes
différentes filières différentes
orientations mais tu vas pas forcément
avoir confiance conscience que certaines
sont plus valorisé socialement que
d'autres et que elles sont plus
rentables en termes d'investissements
scolaire par exemple
ça c'est le premier le premier handicap
que tu peux avoir au niveau de
l'héritage culturel le deuxième le
deuxième handicap c'est le langage
évidemment le langage à l'école ont fait
80 pour 180 180 % du temps est consacré
au langage écrit donc si tu maîtrises
déjà par ton histoire familiale ce
langage écrit tu arrives avec une une
avantage tu commences un peu avec un
avantage dans le système scolaire mais
tu as aussi évidemment tout ce qui est
lié au contenu c'est ce que je disais
pas imaginer un élève qui a qui a déjà
l'occasion de pratiquer des langues
étrangères ou les parents sont
passionnés de chanson française outre
choses comme ça ben voila tu vas avoir
aussi un avantage moi je me suis à vous
je suis en fait pour être transparents
et vous jeu provient d'un milieu
populaire et mes parents ben voilà il
avait des disques emi avait pas
forcément de la belle chanson de la
belle chanson française
à textes des chanteurs à textes il
n'avait pas forcément quand ils avaient
soit de la grande variété ou les textes
n'ont aucune profondeur ou alors des
trucs au style la danse des canards tu
vois et mon prof de français ça c'était
en quatrième secondaire donc en france l
équivalent de la troisième en troisième
nous avait demandé de venir avec une
chanson comme ça pour l'analyser quoi
mais chez nous on n'avait rien analyse
et si tu veux parce qu'on n'avait pas de
chansons à texte et toi ça c'est par
exemple le genre de handicap de contenus
que tu peux avoir quoi et puis il ya
évidemment toute la question de
l'habitus le système scolaire demande et
on va le voir ici dans cet article
demande une certaine docilité et c'est
certaines catégories sociales qui vont
être plus
docile ou qui vont être plus conformes
ou en tout cas vont plus se conformer
aux attentes du système scolaire souvent
des classes des classes moyennes
notamment cieux si on en suit bourdieu
et donc tu vois l'handicap ce que
l'handicap culturel que tu peux avoir
l'école qui va faire que l'école n'est
pas une méritocratie je reviens sur ta
question bien se joue à plusieurs étages
en fait après voilà ça c'est l'analyse
de bourdieu
alors romain pourrait être chef
d'entreprise et recruter je remarque en
bout de chaîne que les bacs plus elle
bac + 5 viennent quasi tous des mêmes
milieux professionnels preuve que
l'origine sociale influent sur le niveau
d'étude même milieu social oui c'est sur
sajoo 1 par ses effets la après tu vas
voir ici ça on en parle un peu moins
c'est pas l'objet de l'article mais
c'est sûr que la méritocratie une fois
tu t'intéresses aux sciences sociales tu
sais c'est un des premiers trucs que tu
découvres que la méritocratie à l'école
elle n'existe pas maintenant voilà ça
veut pas dire qu'il ya quand même pas du
mérite à ceux qui qui qui arrivent au
bout de leurs études c'est pas parce que
tu viens d'une famille aisée que tu vas
forcément on ne faisant rien à voir
obtenir les résultats auxquels tu peux
prétendre donc
il faut faut garder toutes proportions
mais c'est clair que si tu viens d'un
milieu défavorisé tu as de plusieurs
handicaps qui joue quoi après voilà ça
c'est l'explication de bourdieu de
bourru dubourdieu tu as boudon sur la
société que j'avais fait une vidéo à
cette course qui parle de de l'inégalité
des chances par boudon à lui il va
plutôt voir un calcul des gens en fait
si tes parents sont relativement
modestes ils vont pas forcément te
pousser vers les plus hauts niveaux
d'études parce que pour eux déjà dépassé
leur niveau d'étude à eux c'est déjà une
réussite si tu veux et donc on constate
que les les classes les plus populaires
vont choisir des branches plus courte un
style des bac + 3
voilà ça c'est une autre explication
mais voilà si ça vous intéresse je
pourrais regarder pour une sélection
d'articles vraiment sur les inégalités
scolaires mais j'en ai déjà pas mal
parlé sur sur la chaîne youtube donc ça
il faut pas hésiter à aller un petit peu
fouillé dans tout ça quoi
voilà ici c'est un peu c'est un peu un
article qui touche à ça qui est un peu
lié mon nez sur une autre problématique
quand même
là alors je lisais ici tak tak que
zimmerman
quand elle traite de l'expérience
professionnelle l'expérience scolaire
représente d'une part l'appropriation
progressive de ce qui permet de définir
l'enfant comme élève avoir l'expérience
du monde scolaire et d'autre part une
mise à l'épreuve de cette population au
regard de ce que demande l'institution
faire l'expérience du monde scolaire ces
deux dimensions sont difficilement
séparables dans la mesure où la mise à
l'épreuve de l'élève est quasiment
constante dans l'univers scolaire tu
dois faire tout le temps des preuves
dans l'univers scolaire il ya une très
grosse pression et moi je ressens ça de
la part des élèves est alors quand il y
avait eu le premier confinement il ya
des élèves quand on a repris le chemin
des classes qui m'ont dit j'avais fait
un petit peu un cercle de parole pour
savoir comment il avait vécu pendant le
confinement et tout ça et m'ont dit mais
monsieur pendant le confinement vous
avez continué vous et les eaux et les
autres profs à nous envoyer du travail
on a continué à travailler pour l'école
mont était zen on était sereins n'y
avait pas cette pression scolaire de
tout le temps voilà être
dans mii dans une case
devoir de se voir se tenir correctement
sur une chaise pendant 50 minutes où
pendant plus de devoir remettre les
travaux vraiment il ya un
rythme scolaire qui est parfois moi je
trouve même parfois abrutissant et je le
vivais comme ça quand j'étais élève
aussi en secondaire
voilà et donc c'est ce qu'on nous dit
ici on nous confirme l'univers scolaire
demande quand même un conformisme
constant ou une mise à l'épreuve en tout
cas constante notamment ce qui concerne
les comportements attendus à l'école et
qu'elle nourrit l'intériorisation des
normes et des attitudes qui constitue le
métier d'élève hélas oui si ça vous
intéresse on peut faire le lien avec
bourdieu 1 parce que le métier d'élève
ou est ce qu il s'apprend moi j'ai
jamais vu de formation suivez cette
formation ou un cours tient aujourd'hui
on va vous apprendre le métier d'élève
non tu la prend sur le tas
mais certains élèves arrivent déjà un
peu formaté si tu veux par le milieu
familial je prends toujours l'exemple de
certains milieux où la discussion est
super importante on va dire aux enfants
allez vas-y explique moi tu es un petit
peu ce que tu penses tu tiens tu n'as
pas l'air bien pourquoi est-ce que tu
n'as pas l'air bien mais un peu des mots
sur ce que tu ressens la tout ça et donc
à des élèves qui dans le milieu familial
vont développer une verbalisation vont
développer une capacité à exprimer des
émotions avec des des tournures de
phrases complexes avec des qualificatifs
complexe que dans un milieu où on va
être plus plus autoritaire où
l'organisation familiale est beaucoup
plus autoritaire ou alors où les parents
sont carrément démissionnaires ou
absents mais tu n'auras pas cet effort
ça va être c'est comme ça et pas
autrement et on pourra même avoir un
certain usage de la force dans cette
famille là l'élève va l'enfant n'aura
pas l'occasion de verbaliser de la même
manière il répondra aussi par la
violence peut-être le fût ce que la
violence verbale c'est pas forcément une
violence physique il va extérioriser des
choses comme ça et donc prend un enfant
qui a été élevé comme ça qui pour lui la
normalité du monde c'est finalement de
s'exprimer fort d'en venir aux mains
quand quand il y en a manqué de respect
des choses comme ça j'invente il arrive
dans le milieu scolaire il est
complètement déconnecté il est vraiment
décalage tandis que les l'enfant qui a
été élevé dans la famille on verbalise
beaucoup plus ont valu à on va arriver
tiens qu'est ce que tu penses de ce
texte il a déjà tout le logiciel pour
pouvoir s'intégrer dans la chose
scolaire si tu veux il a déjà intégré
une partie du métier d'élève de plus si
dans les activités on l'a mis dans des
stages on l'a mis dans des activités
comme la musique voilà que des cours de
solfège et tout ça il ya une expérience
aussi de la position assise de rester
assis du de pardon des étages détache
complètement intellectuelle et il ya
déjà intériorisé ce métier d'élève et
quand ils arrivent à l'école pour lui
finalement le décalage entre son milieu
nos milieux quotidien et dans lequel il
vit et le milieu scolaire va être très
ténue tandis que certains autres enfants
arrivent avec un gros décalage qu'on a
un gap énorme quoi et donc c'est là
aussi que s'explique les inégalités et
les décalages que tu vois aux romains
dents dans la profession dans ses
activités
l'enfant perçoit très tôt quatre élèves
suppose d'adopter une posture être assis
relativement immobile silencieux alors
souvent je montre aux élèves des vidéos
de milieux de milieux familiaux de
familles dans lesquelles le bruit est
permanent quoi on gueule tout le temps
et pas pour forcément dire des choses
négatives mais c'est le mode de
communication de par l'effort de parler
de manière directe de manière éloquente
avec des grimaces beaucoup c'est élèves
là au niveau de la communication il
arrive au dans le monde scolaire où tout
le monde doit se taire on doit lever la
main pour parler là jeudi le gappi
l'énorme quoi et que cette posture et
mise à l'épreuve plus ou moins
régulièrement par le regard du maître
oued et que l'enfant et commence à avoir
un commence à bouger sur sa chaise et
tout ça on le dit tiens toi 30 il veut
bien rester tranquille et donc ce qui
rappelle à l'ordre qui l'eu socialise au
monde scolaire mais qui est pas évident
pour tous les enfants
alors on va ramener souvent ça des
qualités innées mais les sciences
sociales sont là pour déconstruire tout
ce qui apparaît de prime abord comines
et est finalement ben voilà ce sont des
apprentissages qui ont été faits dans la
famille de certains modes de
comportement talent à cet égard
l'expérience scolaire constitue une
forme de socialisation on verra plus bas
combien cette expérience est prégnante
dans le témoignage des élèves qui ont
décroché il ya quelque chose qui est mal
vécu par les élèves qui ont décroché et
ce mal vécu est liée à toutes ces normes
scolaires
implicite parce qu'elles ne sont pas dit
de manière tout le temps explicite
encore une fois il n'y a pas de de cours
pour apprendre comment bien se tenir à
l'école c'est des trucs que tu apprends
sur le tas plus ou moins quoi le
décrochage scolaire peut être objective
et dont le parcours d'un élève notamment
à partir des critères administratifs et
donc ça c'est le côté un peu facile
entre guillemets du décrochage scolaire
c'est qu'il suffit de regarder dans les
bases de données de l'éducation
nationale ou du ministère de
l'enseignement pour voir qui est en
absentéisme chronique comme ils le
disent ici ou qui est en situation
d'élèves libre en belgique on appelle ça
un élève libre c'est un élève qui ne
vient plus à l'école qui est inscrit
comme un élève voilà en situation de
décrochage donc tu sais très vite ciblée
est à population cible ça c'est quand
même un côté sympa de de cet objet
d'étude jeudi un côté sympa évidemment
c'est pas sur le fond c'est sur la
méthodologie il constitue aussi une
expérience subjective au double sens
mentionné plus haut dont on a parlé il
ne faut bien sûr pas confondre ces
motifs auto rapporté avec des facteurs
explicatifs donc ici les auteurs nous
rappelle que c'est pas parce que les
gens vont dire qu'ils ont décroché à
cause de ça que c'est la cause réelle ça
ce sont des causes qui sont vécus comme
ça donc plutôt des motifs c'est la
différence entre un motif est une cause
ou un facteur ça il faut bien faire
attention et parfois les élèves quand
ils font des enquêtes ou des
questionnaires ils posent des questions
du style
[Musique]
vous pensez que c'est la cause de quoi
et finalement ils pensent que c'est la
cause réelle non les gens ils peuvent
être juste pas conscients des causes
plus générales
auxquelles ils sont confrontés parfois
ils peuvent être conscients parfois
c'est à moitié conscient ça dépend quoi
la recherche sur les facteurs de
décrochage scolaire montre notamment le
caractère déterminant des difficultés
d'apprentissage ce qu'on ne trouve guère
dans les quelques travaux existants sur
le motif de décrochage
donc
voilà c'est lié aussi à des difficultés
d'apprentissage et tu vois directement
vers quoi on va on va sur des élèves qui
en fait ne s'en sort pas l'école donc ce
n'est pas une difficulté alors après
moi ça me fait toujours rire quand on
essaie de raccrocher des élèves qui ont
subi du décrochage scolaire qu est ce qu
on leur met on leur remet une couche
d'école quoi c'est un peu paradoxal
puisqu'ils l'ont décrochée souvent à
cause de ça
par exemple la rupture scolaire peut
être attribuée à des difficultés
familiales ou à la nécessité d'exercer
un emploi pour subvenir à ses besoins on
peut donc distinguer les motifs selon
qu'ils sont internes ou externes à
l'institution scolaire donc là il ya une
première qui paulo gic est proposé et en
sciences sociales on adore faire des
typologies parce que c'est ce qui permet
finalement d'analyser la réalité
le parcours scolaire d'un individu
s'inscrit dans un ensemble du contexte
on l'a déjà dit et notamment
l'environnement familial dont on connaît
les effets importants sur la réussite ou
l'échec scolaire c'est un petit peu ce
qu'on disait aussi tout à l'heure
dans notre scolarité nous sommes dans la
socialisation primaire mais sommes-nous
en fin de scolarité dans notre
socialisation secondaire oui hein quand
tu sors de terminale d'un jeune adulte 1
donc je pense que tu as fini ta ta
socialisation primaire il faudrait
vérifier mais je pense que souvent on
dit que la socialisation primaires c'est
justement pendant l'école primaire fois
là jusque 12 13 ans jusque-là puberté
quelque part voilà après tu le sais sans
doute la socialisation secondaire n'est
jamais finie quoi on est toujours
socialiser même si je dis souvent mais
là c'est pas du tout scientifique que
plus on vieillit plus on sans croûte et
plus on reste finalement dans des
ornières
intellectuel que l'on s'est
formé ou que l'on a formé ou qui ont été
formés
indépendamment de
l peut prendre la forme d'une
contamination quand par exemple des
difficultés dans l'environnement
familial affecte négativement le
parcours scolaire des individus mais les
relations entre sphère de vie peuvent
jouer dans le sens de la compensation
donc en fait avoir des difficultés
familiales oui ça peut jouer mais il
peut jouer aussi le fait que tu es super
bien dans ton milieu familial et donc ça
me permet de rester en course dans le
système scolaire même si tu es en
situation de presque décrochage j'ai
envie de dire quand par exemple un jeune
en difficulté scolaire cherche dans le
monde du travail des sources de
valorisation voilà où dans le monde du
travail c'est une autre sphère au niveau
interne les motifs scolaire le
décrochage peuvent être de nature très
différente
voilà c'est ce qu'on explique ici peut y
avoir des problèmes par rapport à des
échecs que tu as connu il peut y avoir
des problèmes par rapport à
l'institution en général par rapport aux
règles dont on a déjà parlé donc tu peux
avoir des causes à la fois externe de
l'environnement mais aussi des causes
bas qui sont liées proprement parler de
l'école
les motifs de décrochage on voit aussi à
la façon dont les individus intériorise
l'expérience colère ou au contraire la
perçoivent comme étrangère si dans sa
famille depuis que tu es tout petit on
dit ah mais tu sais nous on n'était pas
debout à l'école là tu sais ici on n'est
pas doué dans l'école on va en fait
naturaliser le fait qu' on a une
expérience scolaire négative et que tout
ça est lié à des caractéristiques
individuelles qui se reproduiraient de
génération en génération
alors que c'est justement ce discours-là
qui pénalise et ça devient en quelque
sorte une prophétie auto-réalisatrice si
tu veux
et puis l'enfant et revient de l'école
ouais mais moi l'école ça va pas bah
ouais c'est comme moi et puis voilà on
les parents confirme le verdict de
d'inaptitude scolaire et l'enfant
finalement voilà décrochent de l'école
parce que il ya eu aucun
aucune possibilité d'un accrochage dans
le milieu familial quoi alors voilà le
mot est lancé ici c'est un véritable
habitus scolaire qui se met en place qui
génère la disposition au travail
scolaire permettant la réussite alors le
le terme le concept d'habitude ça a été
un petit peu kidnappé par bourdieu donc
je sais pas si ici on le formule
vraiment dans le sens de bourdieu
généralement c'est par rapport à
bourdieu mais il faut toujours être
prudent mais si c'est dans le sens de
bourdieu pour rappel ce qu'est un
habitus c'est à la fois un générateur de
pratique donc c'est un petit peu des
dispositions que tu as des réflexes de
penser que tu as qui te font comporter
d'une certaine manière par exemple dans
certains milieux tu va choisir
l'objet le moins cher parce qu'il a la
même fonction donc tu vas pas prendre
une poubelle de designers à 100 balles
tu vas prendre plutôt une poubelle chez
action à cinq balles parce que tu
trouves que voilà pour la même fonction
tu vas faire une affaire étant donné la
différence de prix qu'il y a donc tu as
une disposition comme ça à chercher par
exemple un rapport
coût bénéfices quand tu fais des achats
ça va être vraiment une sorte de
logiciel que tu as et qui va générer des
pratiques parce que ça va se transposer
à plein plein de milieux style tu vas
peut-être aller plus en bibliothèque
parce que voilà tu vas pouvoir emprunter
le bouquin où tu vas peut-être
demander le bouquin apprêtez vous me
demandez un objet à prêter plutôt que
l'acheter parce que tu es toujours dans
une recherche finalement de payer le
moins cher pour en avoir le maximum
quelque part c'est vraiment caricatural
comme exemple c'est pour qu'on comprenne
bien mais c'est aussi du coup un système
de valeurs un système de valeurs ce sont
des jugements tu va opérer à partir de
cet habitus ah ouais quand tu vois des
mecs qui vont dépenser s'emballe pour
une poubelle ou septembre des trucs de
designers des chaises designer et tout
ça tu vas dire mais ils sont cons quoi
ils sont comptent dépenser autant et ça
ça vaut pas parce que moins cher c'est
pas forcément de moins bonne qualité tu
peux juste la marque ils sont
complètement débile donc on voit ici que
l'habitus il te fait te comporter d'une
certaine manière mais aussi juger les
autres et tu juges quoi chez les autres
leur habitus a eu quoi donc c'est tout
le modèle de bourdieu 1 par rapport à la
pratique aux pratiques culturelle par
rapport au comportement et tout ça c'est
un modèle positionnelle quoi les gens
réagissent aussi par rapport à ce que
font les autres et ça parfois ne le
comprend pas c'est bien mais je vais
bientôt sortir une vidéo sur bourdieu
sur l'habitude des classes dominantes
c'est en cours ben voila si tu as déjà
lu mon dieu tu sais que beaulieu c'est
assez c'est assez difficile à lire alors
je te dis pas c'est un téthys et c'est
vraiment c'est le parcours du combattant
mais bon je trouve que c'est super
intéressant à faire moi ça me permet
vraiment d'aller au fond du texte et il
ya un bon retour sur ces vidéos sur
youtube déjà pas mal j'ai déjà bien
travaillé sur la distinction c'est
bientôt fini me reste à ce chapitre là
deux autres encore peut-être du chapitre
mais j'aurai fini vraiment une synthèse
en tout cas une vulgarisation la
distinction est une vulgarisation qui va
au fond du texte quelque part parce que
les grosses vulgarisation à la louche de
boudu c'est vraiment parfois caricaturé
mais c'est pas évident forcément donc
voilà le terme d'habitus l'expérience du
décrochage scolaire peut être à leur
vécu de deux manières opposés soit une
disqualification personnel je ne suis
pas fait pour l'école je suis en
situation d'incapacité je suis incapable
ou une situation d'opposition
on s'oppose au modèle scolaire mais
c'est quoi ce bordel de système scolaire
c'est pas possible ils m'en veulent de
toute façon c'est quoi ce ce truc ça
sert à rien l'école sert à rien et là on
va rentrer plus tôt dans une déviance
scolaire qu'est ce que la déviance c'est
quand tu t'écartes des normes des normes
sociales ça veut pas dire forcément des
règlements d'école et tout ça c'est des
normes sociales donc tu rejette en bloc
le fait la grosse normes sociales qui et
voilà on va à l'école quand on est un
enfant et on se tient bien à l'école et
ainsi de suite quoi
elle peut par ailleurs porté sur le sens
donné aux apprentissages scolaires ou
aux méthodes pédagogiques
voilà ce qu'on apprend à l'école ça sert
à rien par rapport au monde
professionnel ou alors les profs ils
rendent toujours tous les trucs chiants
c'est chiant
[Musique]
la légitimité même de la forme scolaire
telle qu'elle est vécue par l'élève
c'est ça qui remet en question sa
légitimité du système scolaire
le processus de subjectivation donc
comment pensent l'élève qui décroche
dans ce cas peut articuler rejet de
l'institution et attraits vers d'autres
sphères de la vie donc d'un côté l'élève
qui est en situation de décrochage va
rejeter le système scolaire mais
valorise ou survalorise même interprète
parce qu'ils disent pas survalorisé le
monde du travail par exemple on a
beaucoup d'enfants qui voit là vers 14
ans disent non mais moi je vais
travailler comme mes parents et tout ça
d'ailleurs quand je vais chez mon
garagiste
maintenant c'est son fils mais je crois
qu'il sait pas s'il a encore scolarisés
quoi il revenait de l'école le gamin il
avait 15 ans et venait déjà chipoter
dans les bagnoles quoi lui voulait être
dans le garage de son père quoi
mais voilà il va survalorisé et donc je
dis pas que le fils de mon garagiste et
en étant d'écrin décrochage scolaire
mais je veux dire voilà ça pourrait être
le type de mec qui décide finalement
d'arrêter l'école parce qu'ils ne
trouvent pas trop sont contre mais
surtout parce que il a un projet ou en
tout cas dans sa tête il est très
motivée par un projet professionnel
après on le dira plus loin ce qui est
paradoxal c'est par contre c'est que les
élèves qui sont en décrochage scolaire
sortent de l'école souvent son diplôme
et donc finalement arrive très très peu
à se reconvertir sur le marché
professionnel enfin sur le marché du
travail pardon
alors ici on passe sur la méthode sur la
méthode d'observation
comment est ce qu'ils vont faire et tout
ce qu'on a dit avant c'est un petit peu
ce que les lectures ce que les travaux
déjà de sciences sociales pouvaient dire
de cet objet d'étude l'a donc finalement
ils ont construit toute une
problématique autour de différentes
lectures qu'il pouvait faire et là ils
vont ils vont entrer dans le vif du
sujet et donc toute cette partie
empirique 1 pour celui qui use celles
qui ne sais pas c'est quoi lampiris
qu'on dit empirique c'est simplement le
fait d'observer la réalité il ya plein
de méthodes possibles mais j'ai envie de
dire ça c'est un peu comme voilà si dans
les sciences naturelles que prend un
thermomètre pour mesurer la température
d'une solution ben voilà on observe la
température de l'absolu de la solution
bien voile en sciences sociales on va
observer avec d'autres outils évidemment
la réalité qui nous entoure la réalité
sociale
alors ici la méthodologie et
quantitatives ils vont recueillir des
données à partir d'un questionnaire et
on va nous parler un peu du
questionnaire dans un encadré
et donc ils vont essayer de définir
certaine régularité c'est que le but des
sciences sociales
ils vont bien sûr posé les questions
classiques les caractéristiques
sociologiques des individus le genre le
milieu social mais aussi évidemment des
éléments caractéristiques du parcours
scolaire comme le redoublement le niveau
de formation atteint au final au moment
du décrochage scolaire
première approche 1 le questionnaire va
être structuré en deux parties la
première partie va plutôt être une
question ouverte pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pose des questions ouvertes au début
d'un questionnaire c'est pour essayer de
recueillir la pensée ou le vécu de la
personne que tu interroges de manière la
plus brute possible sans interférence
parce que dès que tu vas lui proposer
par exemple des questions beaucoup plus
fermé ou des questions à choix multiples
il va se dire ah oui c'est ça que
l'enquêteur veut que je réponde et donc
il va y avoir une forme de
de conformisme qui va faire que la
personne va va répondre des choses que
peut-être l ont jamais répondu si tu lui
a pas posé certaines questions et donc
là on est vraiment sur la création d'un
artefact un artefact c'est quelque chose
que le chercheur a créé lui-même en fait
qu'il n'aurait pas existé si on n'avait
pas administrer le questionnaire donc
c'est vraiment très important d'être
rigoureux par rapport à ça et donc le
conseil basique à la base de la
formation c'est de dire aux élèves vous
mettez des questions ouvertes avant des
questions plus fermé et donc c'est ce
qu'on fait ici on demande simplement le
motif de décrochage de l'élève pourquoi
avez-vous interrompu vos études question
très simple
remarque aussi j'ai souvent des élèves
qui vont multiplier les questions non un
certain moment tu as pas besoin de
mettre des questions pour désir de
mettre des questions ça va allonger ton
questionnaire ça va de te donner
beaucoup plus de travail dans le
traitement de tous les questionnaires
voilà et si cette question ouverte tu va
déjà avoir plein d'informations à
traiter voilà que te casse pas la tête
une seule question ouverte bien formulé
comme celle ci c'est largement suffisant
quand tu veut recueillir voilà des
motifs de manière spontanée
et c'est ce qu'on précise ici ne
comportait volontairement aucune
référence au décrochage ou à ces dérives
et donc décroché décrochèrent tous ces
termes là ont été évacués de cette
question afin de ne pas
comment dire coller l'étiquette de
décrocheurs et que l'élève finalement se
met dans son rôle de décrocheurs ici on
essaie d'avoir vraiment la question la
plus aseptisée possible
la question était posée en début
d'entretien là encore pour éviter les
biais méthodologiques éventuellement
provoquée par l'effet des questions qui
suivait sur le parcours scolaire tu vois
c'est exactement ce que j'expliquais
ensuite il y aura
non pardon on est toujours dans la
première partie ici l'objectif de cette
approche est d'identifier des types de
discours donc d'essayer d'avoir une
typologie de différentes familles de
réponse
est ici on à
2946 répondant ce qui est pas mal hein
alors pour te donner une idée si tu sais
pas si 2946 et beaucoup ont déjà essayé
de faire un questionnaire sur le net tu
verras compères réponse tu auras
bonjour je vois qu'il ya alexandre qui
nous a rejoint et ainsi que je ne sais
pas qui un peut-être un troll russe
voilà c'est un peu d'actualité
voilà bienvenue sur le tchat bienvenue
sur le stream donc l'idée si vous êtes
nouveau c'est que on
vulgarise un article de sciences
sociales
pourquoi est-ce qu'il a choisi une
méthode quantitative et non qualitatif
ça je n'en sais strictement rien je
pense pas que ce soit précisée dans dans
l'article voilà ça serait intéressant
tu touches voilà parfois on aimerait
bien avoir les auteurs des articles pour
vous leur posez différentes questions
comme celle là
moi je vais vous dire mon rêve caché
c'est que ces stream marche bien bon il
marche déjà très très bien voilà la
preuve vous êtes présent et on interagit
c'est super c'est le but de ces stream
mais voilà s'il marche vraiment bien que
la chaîne switch se développe l'idée ce
serait d'inviter en direct des
chercheurs parfois pour pour leur poser
des questions sur des articles qu'on
aurait lu ensemble ou sur de leurs
recherches en général donc moi ça serait
vraiment là où j'aimerais aller où après
voilà je suis pas encore la chaîne n'est
pas encore assez importante que pour
avoir une légitimité j'ai envie de dire
ici sur youtube on commence voilà être
une petite chaîne respectable de onze
mille abonnés voilà quand on aura encore
grandi si si c'est possible et bien ce
moment là on invitera directement les
chercheurs pour leur poser ces questions
là par exemple
je sais pas pourquoi il est parti sur
dufaye son parti sur du quantitatif
après moi je trouve ça intéressant parce
que ça permet d'objectiver je sais pas
ce que tu en penses un requin mais quand
on est ce que sur du qualitatif
après tu te pose toujours la question
ben ouais jusqu'à où c'est transposable
et on en aura envie de savoir si si
c'est les conclusions sont valables dans
d'autres contextes je reprends l'exemple
de cet article de thibaut baisse de 10
sur le monde des sans-abri lui il
observe les sans abri de nancy de la
ville de nancy
après tu sais pas si c'est les mêmes
structures dans d'autres villes tu vois
moi j'aurais envie que d'une chose c'est
que il ya d'autres recherches qu'ils
soient faites pour voir si si le modèle
est transposable vraiment par curiosité
intellectuelle donc c'est les limites du
qualitatif c'est important qualitatif
j'aime bien la recherche qualitative
aussi mais j'aime bien aussi des
recherches quantitatives qui permettent
d'avoir une situation quand beaucoup
plus représentative quelque part
alors moi je vais te dire j'ai très peu
lu bernard lahire c'est vraiment dans ma
liste de lecture mais
j'ai lu quelques articles je sais plus
où moins sur quoi portent ces travaux
mais j'ai jamais lu bernard l'oeil voilà
là beaucoup d'auteurs que j'ai pas
encore lu donc ça ça va venir mais voilà
c'est pas tout lire
puis voilà c'est normalement le problème
de des sciences sociales mais de
n'importe quel domaine c'est si tu veux
pas papillonner et finalement si tu veux
vraiment comprendre certaines choses en
profondeur tu es obligé de consacrer
beaucoup de temps à un seul auteur moi
je suis fort sur sur bourdieu et je vais
te dire je suis fort sur brudieux juste
fort sur la distinction c'est un livre
que je lis que je relis et relis
pour essayer vraiment de comprendre
toutes les subtilités du truc alors
peut-être que je suis trop scolaire dans
mon approche c'est peut-être mon
habitude de classe qui veut ça mais
nietzsche disait finalement tu peux
passer ta vie je suis plus comme je le
disais comment comment il le disait mais
tu peux pas commencer à papillonner
finalement sinon c'est du loisir et ses
plus de l'étude et moi j'ai envie
d'avoir vraiment d'étudier des auteurs
et donc c'est un peu le problème une
fois que tu t'intéresses vraiment en
profondeur à des à des domaines des
champs d'étude sais que tu es quand même
très frustré quoi c'est très frustant
parce que tu lis beaucoup et tu avances
pas forcément et voilà je dis tu dis tu
dis l'aïr moi j'ai envie de lire la
gelée encore je me suis encore dit il
faut que je lise des trucs de l'aïr ici
j'ai encore vu un bouquin dans les
propositions amazon quand j'ai su amazon
je vois des propositions et usages ya ça
va être super intéressant ou des résumés
d'articles et finalement voilà tu as
l'impression de ne pas avancer mais
n'hésite pas si tu peux être précis sur
sur la ive enfin moi ce que je sais de
l'aïr c'est que lui va beaucoup plus
loin de bourdieu d'ailleurs parfois en
l'oppose à bourdieu mais apparemment
c'est quand même des
fausses polémiques où lui et c'est
vraiment de comprendre à cheval en fête
entre de la psychologie et de la
sociologie le parcours d'être des
individus voilà ça c'est un petit peu ce
que ce que je comprends de l'aïr quoi
voilà ici encore crozier friedberg
l'acteur est le système qui est un
classique de 1977 de sociologie
franchement si vous amenez la sociologie
des organisations
comment fonctionnent les entreprises
comment fonctionne l'administration il
faut lire ce livre c'est vraiment un
classique de chez classique et pas plus
tard qu'hier aussi il faut que je le
relise tu vois donc hier en plus de lire
un nouveau truc il faut relire parfois
faire moi j'ai le plaisir de re lire des
trucs j'ai pu depuis un certain temps et
donc je n'avance pas dans mes lectures
garde ici j'ai encore de la bibliothèque
et de du libraire voilà microcosme de
bourdieu bon ça c'est un bon petit
bouquin voilà qui va prendre un certain
temps et regarde ici ce que je ramenais
de la bibliothèque
modélisation statistique appliquée aux
sciences sociales donc là on est
vraiment sûr de la stat appliquées aux
sciences sociales avec plein d'exercices
des choses comme ça bonjour prof le nain
mais quel beau nom
donc pro fln a ici voilà je suis prof
aussi et on vulgarise un article de
sciences sociales un article
scientifique on l'expliquait manière
coup là après on débat un petit peu on
répond aux questions c'est cool hein on
se prend pas trop la tête mais
j'expliquais que voilà si on veut un
certain armand
comment dire je vais pas dire progressé
mais si on veut connaître vraiment des
théories en profondeur faut vraiment
mettre beaucoup d'énergie et si vous
êtes encore étudiant je vais vous dire
un truc donc quand j'étais étudiant donc
j'ai fait un master enfin l'époque
c'était une licence en sciences
politiques et sociales
bon voila j'ai bien travaillé c'est pas
ça mais j'ai fait beaucoup la fête
j'étais un grand fêtard dans les
associations étudiantes des choses comme
ça et aujourd'hui âgée 43 ans je me dis
mais si je pouvais revenir en arrière si
j'avais le voeu d'un bon génie pour
pouvoir faire un voeu je demanderai de
revenir en arrière pour profiter un peu
plus du temps que j'avais quand j'étais
étudiant parfois j'ai consacré mon temps
à des bêtises quoi ce que j'appelle des
bêtises enfin rien faire à jouer aux
jeux vidéo enfin vous allez me dire
c'est cool les jeux vidéo c'est sûr
qu'il ya des jeux vidéos qui sont coulés
et qu'on peut vraiment
c'est pas nourrir là dedans mais je
regrette de ne pas avoir consacré plus
de temps d'étude que j'avais puis quand
à 15 heures de course mais bon tu fais
des travaux que meta du temps pour lire
quoi pour lire les auteurs qui ont
convoyé au cours pour vraiment
m'investir à fond dans des lectures quoi
alors j'ai commencé vraiment à le faire
en dernière année là j'ai commencé
vraiment à lire beaucoup mais pas encore
assez par rapport à ce que j'aurais pu
faire et c'est comme voilà s'il ya des
domaines voilà si si si la ire tu ne te
plaît un requin
je sais pas voilà je sais pas ce que tu
fais tout ça mais aussi tu as l'occasion
d'aller voir des conférences de l'aïr en
direct de de le rencontrer voilà c'est
des choses qu'il faut faire vous rendez
compte moi j'adore pierre bourdieu
j'adore j'aime beaucoup ce qu'a fait
pierre bourdieu pardon on va pas adoré
ici mais il est mort en 2002 j'étais
encore aux études j'aurais pu aller
assister à une conférence j'aurais pu
aller au collège de france je n'ai pas
fait parce qu'à l'époque voilà tu es
jeune tu penses pas à faire tout ça mais
finalement c'est des trucs après c'est
trop tard quoi trop tard d'auxi si j'ai
un conseil si vous êtes aux études que
vous faites des sciences sociales et que
ça vous botte un que vous êtes vraiment
dans votre élément aller franchement
consacrer une fois par mois à une sortie
voilà allez voir des conférences aller à
faire des lectures allez vous acheter un
bouquin même si vous lisez pas
entièrement voilà le biotech parfois je
vois la bibliothèque je vois plein de
bouquins que j'adorerais lire y en a
partout quoi et alors
les mecs et les filles qui sont là-bas
finalement ils bossent sur leurs tricks
font leurs travaux ils étudient leurs
notes de cours et ils vont même pas
cherché les bouquins en bibliothèque
quoi ça je me dis waouh quoi alors qu'il
ya tellement de choses je suis pas
moralisateur je fais pas mon bonheur ici
c'est pour ça que je veux faire mais
pour vous dire voilà si vous êtes encore
aux études allez faites le parce
qu'après vous aurez pu le temps tu vas
être dans le monde professionnel bon en
sciences sociales il faut pas se cacher
a très peu de gens qui font des prêts
des carrière académique ou
voilà il n'y a pas non plus mis lui même
1000 personnes qui vont dans
l'enseignement secondaire n'avait plus
dans l'enseignement scolaire tu as quand
même à un rythme donc tu peux pas avoir
une certaine profondeur dans tes
lectures pas tu peux la voir mais c'est
quand même il ya quand même un rythme de
production de deux courts affaires de
correction un rythme assez abrutissant
et en fait quand tu fais un peu le tour
tu as deux moments de ta vie dans lequel
tu as vraiment l'occasion de lire de
lire des choses profondes des choses
complexes c'est quand tu es étudiant si
tu l'aies et quand
quant à la retraite finalement quoi
c'est un peu dommage d'attendre la
retraite quoi
voilà donc désolé pour la digression
hamon est là pour sa qua na
stream c'est quand même pour un peu
blablater quoi sinon on fait pas un
stream j'aurais fait une vidéo alors
fois ci ça vous embête vous le dit hein
je raconterai - ma vie et et on
discutera moins comme ça les prochaines
fois quoi alors ils ont distingué si
registre
ici
dans leur analyse les dispositions les
motivations la capacité le rejet le
travail et les problèmes personnels et
une deuxième étape de traitement de ces
données a consisté à indexer chaque
réponse en fonction de ces cires jce de
discours afin de mesurer la fréquence de
chaque type de discours donc on va un
petit peu regardé les élèves décrocheurs
s qui sont plutôt dans des questions de
dispositions personnelles simplement ils
n'ont pas les compétences quoi alors je
peux le dire de manière un peu un peu
brutes comme ça il se trouve votre
compte pour faire leurs études j'ai bien
dit se trouve moi je pense que beaucoup
de gens sont capables de faire des
études souvent dans les conseils de
classe j'entends des collègues qui
disent ah mais il n'est pas capable et
tout ça mais qu'est ce qu'on en sait
quoi est ce que est ce qu'on va chercher
tout le potentiel de tout le monde est
ce que tout le monde a eu l'occasion de
révéler du potentiel je pense que pour
faire des études secondaires jusque
jusqu'à un certain niveau voilà qu'il
n'y a pas de souci quand même après je
ne sais pas le niveau du bac en france
puisque moi j'ai pas passer le bac ce
qu'on nourrit en belgique voilà du
secondaire en belgique si tu travailles
je pense qu'il ya moyen donc cette
question des dispositions est
intéressante
la motivation alors personnellement même
pour la réussite scolaire je pense que
la motivation c'est la clef de tout
c'est ce que je disais pourquoi est-ce
que j'ai pas lu pendant mes études
suffisamment mais c'est parce que je
voyais j'étais pas là j'avais pas la
motivation
en
début de cursus corps et c'est seulement
à la fin où j'ai commencé à comprendre
certaines choses
voilà me sentir bien dans le dos des
études et à le faire quand donc tu
trouves la motivation à salma et tu
l'avais pas un autre moment alors
capacités alors je vois pas la
différence ici entre capacité
disposition peut-être que j'ai confondu
les deux mais peut-être qu'on le verra
plus loin de quoi il s'agit le rejet le
rejet de l'école l'attirance pour le
travail pour le monde du travail ou des
problèmes personnels et donc après ils
vont formuler une liste de vingt-trois
motifs qui vont être classés dans ces si
dense et si schéma quoi dans ces six
sites m6 registre pardon définit donc tu
as deux vraiment deux parties dans dans
le questionnaire et regarde ici tu veux
avoir une échelle de likert alors ça
c'est l'échec c'est tout à fait d'accord
d'accord ni d'accord n'y pas d'accord
pas d'accord vraiment pas d'accord que
juste comme ça et donc là c'est inné une
échelle à cinq éléments bon t'as pas
faute d échelle cet élément ça permet de
ne pas mettre
un sens à vie puisque c'est le l'échelon
du milieu qui te sert de 100 avis si les
personnes ne veulent pas trop répondre
ne le savent pas trop elle met le truc
du mieux et donc ça te permet de faire
ce à quoi
bon soir laurent tu vas bien
je ne savais pas que c'était toi mais tu
n'es pas tu n'es pas si petit que ça il
ne faut pas te dévaloriser comme ça
laurent
ça va donc voilà ici on trade
d'un article peut-être que tu l'avais
déjà vu laurent c'était sur le
décrochage scolaire et surtout dans cet
article les chercheurs s'intéressent au
motif que l'élève se donne par rapport à
ce décrochage donc ça c'est c'est assez
intéressant parce qu'apparemment dans la
littérature c'était quelque chose qui
était a assez peu courant ce travail de
subjectivation finalement août aucun en
tout cas de d'observation de cette
subjectivation des parcours
alors à cette fin les 23 propositions
figure est dans le questionnaire chaque
jeune étant invités à se prononcer sur
ses positions je me répète pardon
raisons auxquelles ne pensent pas
spontanément donc l'intérêt 10,6 par
rapport à la première question ouverte
c'est que dans ce cas si tu va permettre
de leur de leur montrer quelque chose
d'exhaustif et pourrait se dire un saint
amand ah oui j'avais pas pensé à ça et
hop il te le coche quoi
les oignons les énoncés ont été choisis
au vu de la littérature existante en
distinguant les motifs externe et
interne de l'institution scolaire quatre
composantes externes ont été identifiés
chacune des composés par deux
propositions en fait je me trompe 1 je
disais que les six registre il allait
utiliser dans la deuxième partie mais
non ils ont repris quatre autres désolé
merci si tu trouves que c'est
intéressant aussi voilà c'est l'idée
alors ben justement par rapport à ce
genre de lecture tu vois moi c'est le
ici ce que je trouve dommage parfois
dans les articles scientifiques
mais il ya un mais je dis tout de suite
ce que je trouve dommage c'est que il
détaille pas suffisamment pour moi moi
je suis lecteur j'ai envie de savoir
vraiment comment ils ont offert en
détail et bien c'est quoi la littérature
existante
tu vois en distinguant les motifs
externe et interne à l'institution
scolaire là ils auraient dû mettre quand
même la référence qui permettrait
d'aller rechercher ça mais bon il en a
déjà parlé plus haut donc c'est
peut-être la même référence mais parfois
moi je trouve que les articles
scientifiques sont pas assez détaillés
maintenant tu me diras si cet été s'il
était plus détaillée et c'est le même
ben tu vois ici il fait déjà quatorze
pages tour un article de 35 pages il ya
déjà personne qui lit les articles
scientifiques sauf sur le stream de la
socio tech et eux
et donc il y aura encore moins de gens
qu'ils iraient qua non c'est dommage tu
vois c'est dommage c'est qu'ici ils vont
parler un petit peu de cette enquête
alors peut-être qu'il ya moyen de les
retrouver voilà ce programme peut-être
qu'avec la référence est loin de le
retrouver mais elle n'est pas
directement dans l'article donc ça c'est
un peu dommage suis d'accord avec toi tu
vois moi je trouve que on devrait avoir
tous les outils méthodologiques et
parfois dans les articles scientifiques
bah quand tu es jeune chercheur quand tu
es profs comme moi de secondaire quand
tu es étudiant tu aimerais vraiment
avoir des exemples et tu les as pas
parce que voilà ça ça reste de la popote
interne c'est un peu dommage c'est un
peu dommage c'est un avis peut-être qu'à
une raison après je vais vous dire moi
j'ai jamais fait partie du monde de la
recherche universitaire donc peut-être
qu'à une raison peut-être que c'est moi
qui manque d'information c'est pour ça
que ce serait intéressant dans le
développement de cette chaîne twitch et
de cette chaîne youtube c'est qu' on
puisse inviter des chercheurs et des
chercheuses
voilà en direct et qu'on puisse faire
vraiment des entretiens qu'on puisse
leur poser des questions ça serait
vraiment chouette donc si vous avez des
amis des amis qui s'intéressent aux
sciences sociales dites leur de venir ne
fut-ce que follow est sûre sur twitch
s'abonner sur youtube pour qu'on ait
vraiment une chaîne
et comme ça légitime par rapport à
parler des sciences sociales c'est moi
je vais vous dire j'ai pas envie de
paraître pour un charlot en invitant un
chercheur et puis après sur le chat on
se retrouve à parfois je suis parfois je
suis tout seul voilà c'est vrai on est
assez bien c'est super sympa je vous
remercie d'ailleurs d'être là mais voilà
il faut que la chaîne et une certain un
certain poids quoi
on fait tous ont fait toutes les
sciences sociales en sachant que voilà
moi je me présente pas comme un
spécialiste je vulgarise je propose des
lectures sur la chaîne youtube tu
trouves des vidéos j'ai fait d'ailleurs
une vidéo d'un article qui parlait
d'anthropologie un look tu peut la
retrouver c'était sur la fait entendre
que vite qu'est ce que la fed d'un point
de vue anthropologique est donc là c'est
un article jules garris de manière
beaucoup plus formaté que ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui ça c'est sur la chaîne
youtube mais on fait de tout donc on
fait bien sûr la sociologie ici j'ai
fait récemment et je vous fais de plus
en plus parce que c'est quand même ce
que je préfère c'est la science
politique la science politique
on a déjà fait bien ici tu vois c'est
plutôt des thèmes revue de pédagogie
donc la pédagogie la psychologie
entrepôt communication économie
géographie sociale tout ça voilà on fait
les sciences sociales parce que pour
rappel c'est une chaîne qui au départ
s'adresse aux gens qui débutent donc
l'idée de la chaîne c'est de vulgariser
des bases où quelqu'un voilà de monsieur
madame tout le monde qui voudraient
simplement tiens c'est quoi les sciences
sociales il vient à voir une vidéo de la
chaîne ah bah oui c'est ça voilà quoi ça
c'est l'idée c'est l'idée de vulgariser
au grand public ce que sont les sciences
sociales et des trucs de base pour aider
les gens qui sont non
les élèves d'abord les élèves de
secondaire mais aussi parfois il ya
beaucoup d'étudiants moi j'étais étonné
du nombre d'étudiants qui met un petit
commentaire sur la chaîne youtube en
disant ah c'est super sympa le plus beau
commentaire que j'avais eu à ce niveau
là c'était quelqu'un qui disait ah ben
tu as dix en cinq minutes ce que le prof
a mis trois heures à dire en auditoire
voilà c'est super sympa si je peux
apporter des outils pour que les élèves
ils reviennent du court ils savent plus
trop ce qui a été dit woods absent voilà
il faisait autre chose dans l'auditoire
ils reviennent y voit la vidéo ah ouais
j'ai les bases quoi moi c'est vraiment
l'idée d'aider tout le monde à faire des
sciences sociales du mieux possible
après sans doute que je fais des erreurs
il ya beaucoup de choses que je connais
pas donc si on parle d'anthropologie ou
alors on va vite atteindre le mont
plafond en termes de compétences et de
connaissances mais cette loi sont pas le
but de la chaîne moi c'est pas une
chaîne que je fais pour étaler du savoir
et tout ça le savoir en sciences
sociales je crois que ce n'était pas un
peu humble anciens en sciences sociales
tu vas mal faire les sciences sociales
parce que voilà
et puis de toute façon dans n'importe
quel domaine avec le
nombre de savoir je crois que c'est tous
les dix ans ou tous les cinq ans je sais
plus le chiffre je le disais dans une
vidéo que j'avais fait sur robert merton
et sur l'effet mathieu tous les dix ans
tu as un doublement du
nombre de connaissances du nombre
d'écrits qui ont été faits par la
communauté scientifique donc voila moi
ça fait déjà 20 ans que j'ai fait mes
études donc on a déjà que quadruplé si
je compte bien les choses
alors laurent tu dis lors des cours de
recherches que j'ai eues en haute école
j'avais remarqué la même chose dans les
articles scientifiques un manque de
transparence dans leurs lectures mais
oui et c'est ce qu'on trouve alors après
moi j'ai pas envie qu'on y voit les
sciences sociales ils sont pas assez
rigoureux j'adore la géologie rien à
voir les sciences sociales mais ce
mouvement a mené au but en géologie
parfois c'est un peu la même chose quoi
parfois tu as pas tous les éléments à
disposition
c'est un peu dommage c'est un peu
dommage il faudrait poser la question à
des chercheurs pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'a pas comme tu dis un requin
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas le le
questionnaire quoi qu'est ce que ça leur
coup même dans la distinction talent
questionnaire la fin quoi donc ici tu as
quand même plus de précisions sur cette
enquête alors peut-être qu'ici avec les
informations tu peut la retrouver
personnellement j'ai pas cherché quoi
bon ce qui est comme je le disais ce qui
est super intéressant c'est que tu as
quand même un gros échantillons quoi
2946 c'est quand même assez bien alors
je sais pas si j'ai été au bout de ma
maman idée tout à l'heure par exemple
pour des sondages électoraux comme on en
a beaucoup pour l'instant bien le panel
l'échantillon ses mille personnes donc
ici tant à 2946 ça commence à être pas
mal bon voilà ça c'est les standards
dans une recherche scientifique mais
regarde le nombre de personnes qu'ils
ont dû contacter ils ont contacté 13000
personnes donc serait 13000 ils ont eu
deux 1946 qui ont répondu alors ce qui
est super important si tu veux avoir un
échantillon représentatif c'est un peu
contre intuitif mais la meilleure façon
c'est de tirer au sort c'est la
randomisation donc voila tu dois
connaître ta population cible tu dois
avoir toutes les personnes qui composent
la population cible c'est pas toujours
facile parce que si tu dis voilà je vais
faire une enquête sur tous les élèves du
nord pas de calais toi peut-être qu'à
ton niveau tu peux pas avoir accès aux
bases de données qui permettent d'avoir
tous les noms des élèves du
nord-pas-de-calais et surtout une
adresse mail ou un numéro de téléphone
pour les contacter quoi parce que c'est
injuste leur nombre après j'ai trouvé à
faire avec ça et donc tu met tout dans
un gros chapeau évidemment c'est une
image et une pioche du pioch pour
essayer d'avoir le meilleur échantillons
possible dans
dans les conditions qui sont celles de
ton enquête voilà il faut avoir des
moyens pour traiter tout ça surtout
qu'ici regarde ça a été fait par
téléphone
donc ça a été administré entre avril et
octobre 2015 par voie téléphonique 15
minutes par entretiens bon bah tu fais
le calcul 15 minutes fois de 1946 tu as
le temps qu'il faut consacrer à tout ça
quoi plus évidemment le fait que tu
appelles qu'il n'y a pas forcément
personne donc tu dois avoir une équipe
d'enquêteurs t'avais 91 une question au
total
donc c'est quand même une grosse enquête
et finalement c'est vrai que c'est un
peu dommage de ne pas avoir toutes les
enquêtes mais en tout cas ici on a quand
même un petit peu sa structure voilà tu
avais des propositions et donc ils
devaient se positionner par rapport à
ces propositions tu avais à chaque fois
deux propositions par thème donc sur le
thème mode du travail tu aurais je
voulais avoir une activité
professionnelle pas du tout d'accord
tout à fait d'accord avec les échelons
je voulais gagner de l'argent
l'environnement social mon entourage ne
montraient pas d'intérêt pour mes études
ça c'est quand même super intéressant
quand on veut faire des liens avec
bourdieu personne ne m'aidait à faire
mes devoirs mais ça aussi mais ça aussi
par le zoo parlons-en on parlait des
difficultés
enfin en tout cas de la
surreprésentation de certaines classes
sociales dans les bac + 5 c'était
tout à l'heure c'était c'était c'était
par 15 des romains qui disait ça
mais pourquoi est ce que tu en arrives
là mais parfois tu as des milieux
sociaux dans lesquels ou des
configurations familiales dans lesquels
l'élève l'enfant se retrouve seul pour
faire ses devoirs après il ya des cas
totalement extrême je me souviens d'un
élève dans une école que j'avais dans
laquelle j'avais fait un remplacement ou
les deux parents étaient alcooliques et
donc lui rentré il était en quatrième
secondaire donc c'est l'équivalent de la
troisième en france
il rentrait chez lui et devait mettre
ses parents couches et faire les courses
occupé du petit frère parce que ses
parents étaient ivres nord quoi mais
comment veux-tu après donc déjà il n'a
pas une aide de camp et rentrer à
l'école mais il ya un contexte familial
mais que nocifs après voilà je ne juge
pas les parents c'est parce que je veux
faire ici mais le contexte est nocif
pour ça ce coloris scolarité sans plomb
pourra pas dire le contraire quoi c'est
factuel donc évidemment tu as des élèves
qui secoue ce sont des ressources à la
maison qui peuvent être aidés à la
maison - des enfants voilà sont ma femme
elle est enseignante aussi on les aide
énormément mais voilà c'est pas le cas
de tous les enfants et dont il faut bien
penser que travail à domicile ou études
à domicile c'est souvent synonyme de
d'une accentuation des inégalités
scolaires quoi parce que voilà tout le
monde n'aura pas les mêmes opportunités
évidemment donc ça c'est un élément bon
là je sors du cadre du questionnaire
mais c'est un élément qui est super
important
oui les autres un directif
ouais
donc il fait ça bernard lahire c'est
plutôt des entretiens directif ok c'est
bon à savoir aussi parce que j'essaie
aussi d'illustrer pour mes élèves les
différentes méthodes alors voilà ceux
qui ne connaissent pas les différentes
méthodes d'entretien talent mais de
l'entretien semi directifs ou tuera ce
directif tu vas être très directif comme
le nom l'indiqué donc c'est à mi-chemin
entre un autre entretien libre un récit
de vie et un questionnaire finalement
dans un entretien tu vas pas commencer à
poser des questions trop précises mais
d'entretien directif tu veux que tu as
quand même un canevas respecter voilà
après tu peux avoir des entretiens beau
plus beaucoup plus libre
c'est ya toute une méthodologie mais de
façon si vous êtes dans des recherches
l'idée quand vous faites des sciences
sociales je pense ne pas avoir une
vision complète et exhaustive de chaque
méthode mais quand vous allez faire un
travail voilà documentez-vous dans les
ouvrages de méthodologie sur la méthode
que vous allez employés c'est
généralement comme ça que
de meilleures façons de travailler je
pense
à part dont je pensais que tu faisais
référence à bernard lahire non bon là
c'est
s'aider des questionnaires dont ils ont
vraiment leur ligne de conduite c'est
très fermé c'est des entretiens oui on
peut dire c'est honteux blanc va entre
le questionnaire et l'entretien directif
parfois la limite est ténue mais bon
disons qu'ici a vraiment quelque chose
un canevas vraiment très très précis à
suivre donc oui cela c'est ultra
directif
les conditions matérielles poursuivre
les études mon lieu d'étude était trop
éloigné de mon domicile l'on peut penser
en france ben voilà au petit village de
montagne qui sont perdus voilà peut-être
que pour allah au lycée il ya un bus il
faut faire trois quarts d'heures de bus
pour arriver
don au collège ou au lycée voilà ça peut
être des facteurs démotivant c'est sur
mes études coûtait trop cher des
problèmes de personnel de santé j'avais
beaucoup de problèmes personnels j'ai
été malade j'ai eu un accident
j'attendais un enfant
après bon c'est pas le but ici mais
voilà problème personnel est-ce que
c'est pas une
terminologie trop trop générales quoi
après bon leur but c'est de voir les
facteurs esquissons externe et ce qu'ils
sont internes donc là on dépasse c'est
plutôt dans la première question tu vas
avoir des réponses à qu'elle n'a de
quelle nature étaient les problèmes
personnels
et donc sept composantes internes les
épreuves scolaires le travail demandé
par les enseignants étaient trop
difficiles j'avais peur d'échouer un
rapport au travail scolaire les méthodes
d'enseignement utilisé par les
professeurs ne me convenait pas j'avais
l'impression de perdre mon temps j'en
avais marre de l'école tiens pourquoi
est-ce qu ici à trois items jeu combien
1 2 3 et que
normalement ils avaient dit qu'ils ont
avec deux
bonds pas trop se poser de questions
mais sur sa bizarre rapport aux savoirs
scolaires je trouvais les cours
inintéressant je ne voyais pas l'utilité
de ce que j'apprenais à l'école
relations et des enseignants je ne
m'entendais pas avec les professeurs les
professeurs étaient injustes avec moi
rapport aux autres et au climat scolaire
je ne m'entendais pas avec les autres
élèves les autres élèves ne m'aidait pas
dans mon travail est ici par exemple
encore trois items pourquoi ce que
parfois il ya trois items parce que si
tu mets trois items du coup tu
déséquilibre ton travail et a plus de
champ statistiquement que il te pioche
un de ces trois items là que les
catégories où il ya deux items tu vois
ce que je veux dire donc tu crées un
biais ou peut-être une explication qui
m'a échappé un jeu qui dicte pas le
travail des auteurs je ne permettrai pas
mais c'est une question que je me pose
et que je poserai hauteur 6 s'il était
là
tu vas déséquilibré ton
ton travail quoi
rapport à l'orientation je n'ai pas
obtenu l'information que je souhaitais y
suivre la formation que je suivais ne me
ferai pas de débouchés bon en boutade
alors ne fait pas trop de sciences
sociales desoler
qui aime bien châtie bien rapport aux
normes scolaires j'étais exclu de ma
dernière formation et là on a un seul
items donc satistiques m'en parles en à
chose un champ ses galbes tu auras moins
souvent s'est dit m là qui va ressortir
alors
à temps parce que en fait j'ai un
problème c'est que le chat youtube mais
déjà je vois que le chat youtube n'est
pas bon moi j'ai le bon chat youtube
mais il n'est pas bien afficher sur sur
ce que vous voyez je vais le désactiver
ça sert à rien et en fait je vois toutes
tes questions ici laurent sur youtube
mais tout le monde ne voit pas c'est
dommage pour ce sera pour une prochaine
fois ce n'est jamais que la cinquième ou
sixième fois que j'utilise obs peut-être
un petit peu plus mais bon voilà je suis
encore en apprentissage
merci d'être indulgent c'est une
difficulté récurrente de l'enseignement
des sciences sociales réussir à rester
neutre et humble déconstruire son
positionnement afin d'amener une
réflexion aux élèves vrai tout à fait
voilà et on déconstruit jamais assez et
puis parfois un teint les élèves je sais
pas si tu as a aussi dans tes classes
laurent parfois tu as tes élèves qui
qui demande mais monsieur mais qu'est ce
que vous en pensez vous mais mon avis
n'a aucune importance mon opinion n'a
aucune importance mais parfois les
élèves sont au monde d'opinion quoi
comme s'il avait besoin et c'est
compréhensible aussi comme s'il avait
besoin si tu veux d'un d'inde une
référence pour eux se positionner aussi
bon en sachant que sans doute qu'ils ont
d'autres références je dis pas que le
prof de sciences sociales va être la
seule référence qu'ils auront mais voilà
c'est aussi important je pense pour la
construction des ados qu'ils aient des
des étalons comme ça des des étalons
fait que c'est une mauvaise pauvre image
des références
par rapport auquel ils vont se
positionner quoi mais c'est vrai que
nous en sciences sociales on marche
toujours sur des oeufs comme jeudi
il me semble avoir vu une étude je n'ai
plus de sources en tête qui montrait la
non évolution de la population étudiante
au regard des milieux sociaux toujours
peu d'enfants d'ouvriers ouais ben si ça
vous intéresse
je vais chercher une des enquêtes qui
actualise tout ça vraiment sur les
inégalités scolaires il y en a eu et
j'en ai proposées dans le sondage enfin
dans le choix le petit vote pour savoir
quel article on allait être étais je
pense il ya deux semaines mais il est
pas ressortie mais j'en proposerai gens
proposent toute façon sur les inégalités
scolaires toujours quoi
mais j'imagine pour les problèmes
personnels ils ont reçu tellement
d'informations variées qu'il ne pouvait
pas toutes les listes et ouais c'est sûr
ouais bon après c'est voilà moi je
réagis en tant que prof c'est ce que je
dirai un élève quoi qu'est ce que tu
entends par là toujours nous sommes
malgré tout des repères pour eux oui
c'est important je pense aussi d'avoir
parfois des moments où même le prof
alors je sais pas ce que tu en penses ce
requin par rapport à des professeurs du
supérieur si pour toi c'est aussi
important que parfois le prof se
positionne
alors peut-être moins quand on est
étudiant mais quand on élève qu'on se
construit qu'on était un adolescent
qu'on cherche des repères des exemples
d'adultes j'avais bien aimé je sais pas
si vous aviez eu facile oran toi t'as vu
ce cours là
c'est un cours qui s'appelle style
adolescence et vie scolaire fin c'est un
cours très psychologique sur le
développement de l'adolescent et on nous
avait dit mais rendez vous compte pour
certains enfants
vous êtes les seuls modèles d'adultes
qu'ils vont voir dans leur jeunesse en
dehors de leur milieu familial et là tu
te dis waouh et là tu sens la
responsabilité de l'exemplarité que tu
donnes et voilà je pense que dans ce
cadre là parfois on doit faire des
parenthèses au cours dans lesquels on
doit se positionner bien sûr en le
précisant disant bien voilà que ce n'est
qu'une opinion que ce n'est qu'un avis
personnel que on accepte tout à fait
qu'ils aient d'autres façons de voir les
choses qu'on n'impose pas cette vision
là mais je pense qu'il faut le faire
mais pour qu'ils aient déjà longue c'est
mieux que et alain
ça peut être intéressant d'amener un
point de vue mais uniquement si cela
amène au débat mais c'est très casse
gueule oui et puis ça dépend sur le
thème tu vois sur des thèmes bon
actuellement
les thèmes du genre des choses comme ça
c'est des thèmes qui peuvent être
sensibles parce que tu sais jamais les
situations dans lesquelles sont les
élèves personnels mais aussi par rapport
à leurs parents ou les thèmes politiques
évidemment bon après quand on parle de
termes un petit peu plus un peu plus
comme ical et j'ai envie de dire comme
enfin moi je suis toujours une séquence
sur les prénoms ça peut être casse
gueule aussi parce que si tu as des
prénoms qui sont très connoté dans ta
classe tu peux en donnant des exemples
très vite sortir le prénom est
finalement dire ouais ça fait un peu
prénom de beaufs et finalement voilà que
tu du coup tu ostracisant un élève de sa
classe et là c'est vraiment pas top donc
tous les thèmes sont casse gueule mais
il ya quand même des thèmes qui sont
profondément casse-gueule
psychologie de l'apprentissage a choisi
ce à quoi
voilà
alors qu'un toi tu le dit
personnellement je suis étudiant en
sociologie et je ne souhaite pas avoir
l'avis du professeur cas nous devons au
maximum objective et ouais c'est sûr
aussi un mais je sais pas si tu vois un
petit peu le la position qu'on est en
secondaire et je sais pas si tu quand tu
étais au lycée si tu avais des profs
voilà qui 15 flamand dans des conditions
je dire cadré riffaud pas faire passer
des opinions pour dédé fait ou défait
pour pour des opinions de toutes façons
ça c'est rohff et moins souvent mais
c'est important parfois les jeunes
moi quand ils ont 15 16 ans il aime bien
qu'on va simplement qu'on dise des
choses quoi qu'on dise des choses qu'on
prenne parti sur sur les réelles
mais c'est vrai que ce poisson c'est ce
qui ce fait on fait souvent ça
bien c'est c'est hyper rare
donc ouais c'est sûr enfin voilà une
façon c'est toujours casse gueule des
sciences sociales est ici à une strie
mesin moody qui fait des sciences
sociales mais elle est très engagée sur
certains thèmes et voilà quand tu es
très engagé militant sur certains thèmes
sur des thèmes du genre ou des thèmes de
la déconstruction de certains
stéréotypes
raciaux
ou raciste plus tôt aujourd'hui raciste
voilà c'était parfois un peu militant
sur ces thèmes là et c'est difficile bon
c'est comme je disais au début du stream
m'ont personnellement voilà le programme
de zemmour ce que dit zemmour je trouve
ça profondément dangereuse c'est une
opinion mais un saint amand tu dois
traiter
le comment dire le programme de zemmour
comme tu le fais pour les autres
candidats donc c'est compliqué par
rapport à ta conscience personnelle mais
voilà c'est ce qu'il faudrait il
faudrait une fois interrogé un chercheur
ou vraiment quelqu'un qui a une bonne
pratique des sciences sociales pour voir
comment comment ils arrivent encore à
concilier parfois des opinions avec son
travail parce que parfois tu lui as dit
il ya des choses que sur lesquels tu
fais des blocages quoi
ma main volontaire par là on va pas
faire toute une toute une heure là
dessus car comme on a dit webber dans le
savant et le politique dans un
amphithéâtre le professeur à la parole
et les étudiants sont contraints au
silence ouais tout à fait sauf que
maintenant alors je sais pas toi dans le
dont l'auditoire comment ça se passe
on a quand même on a quand même évolué
là dessus bon le prof que ce soit en
secondaire ou dans le supérieur de façon
à toujours le pouvoir ça c'est sûr mais
tu as quand même les espaces voilà comme
le com switch com comme les réseaux
sociaux dans lesquels
il me semble qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup plus de contre-pouvoirs
peut-être au pouvoir absolu du
professeur côté mme weber autant de
bieber la presse voilà est réservé à une
élite la parole est réservé à une élite
masculine aujourd'hui on est quand même
sur il ya plus de contre-pouvoirs qui
sont possibles donc le prof qui auraient
des positions vraiment des opinions
qu'il ferait passer pour des faits
sociologiques
voilà je pense que ça serait quand même
beaucoup plus difficile aujourd'hui que
du temps de webber alors cela dit au
passage je suppose que tu as tu as lu le
savant et le politique tu a apprécié toi
le bouquin c'est je les lui il n'y a pas
très longtemps je les lui après avoir lu
les règles de la méthode sociologique
peu de durkheim et en fait voilà j'ai
trouvé que bieber ça marche ça m'a
vraiment alors je le dire crûment ça m'a
fait chier quoi le bouquin m'a fait
chier alors que j'avais vu un post sur
un stade qui disaient ouais trop fort le
savant et le politique un truc à lire
tout ça donc je suis arrivé mais c'est
peut-être aussi l'effet que ça a créé de
voir ce post super enthousiaste je suis
arrivé à la lecture et j'ai dit ouais
bof et je trouvais qu'il enfoncé des
portes grandes ouvertes parfois voilà
des trucs qui était totalement dépassée
de trucs plus plus moderne plus actuel
voilà moi j'étais un peu déçu
du bouquin en tout cas des deux
conférences ne sais pas si toi c'est ce
que tend à penser requin c'est
intéressant de ne pouvoir un peu
confrontés
c'est beau ce que tu dit laurent chila
correct hu a montré notre humanité aux
élèves leur montrer que nous avons des
avis et pas uniquement une vision
théorique des choses m'ont montré alors
les avis moi je suis moins d'accord sur
cette partie de la de ton post mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi sur
montrer notre humanité avec nos billets
et avec nos erreurs avec nos jugements
c'est sûr bon allez revenons à nos
moutons c'est passionnant de discuter
comme ça
je vois en regardant la miniature de la
webcam que j'ai pas à lui mais certaines
langues attendez je vais faire un truc
non là je vais être surexposée désolé
c'est peut-être mieux parce qu'en fait
tu vois j'ai un néon l'aide de fin des
délais delà dans le fond et alors quand
je mets pas assez de lumière à ce
moment-là ça bouge tout tout l'image
quoi donc désolé je préfère comme ça
voilà désolé pour ce petit moment
technique et cosmétiques alors revenons
à nos moutons
donc ici après ils ont fait des
classifications ils ont tous classés et
ils ont fait des analyses statistiques
multivariée donc c'est de voir comment
les variables varie selon différents
critères dits selon d'autres variables
n'est pas une seule variable parce que
sinon ça serait une analyse univariée
lacets multivariée et moi c'est le truc
qui pour l'instant voilà je rappelle ma
lecture du moment où en tout cas ce que
je vais commencer ça c'est l'idée quoi
tu vois deux doigts de pouvoir faire des
régressions des machins comme ça pour
quand tu as des analyses quantitatives
sortir des coefficients ça c'est quelque
chose qui est parfois difficile pour les
élèves et peut-être les étudiants un
requin peut être que confirmera c'est
toute la partie statistiques et je vois
parfois même des doctorants qui ont
beaucoup de difficultés avec les stats
parce que quand tu prends les sciences
sociales c'est parfois parce que
peut-être ouais les sciences avec des
grosses mathématiques je sais pas trop
ton truc donc tu veux un truc un peu
littéraire tu vas vers les sciences
sociales et bam tu te rends compte qu'il
ya un peu trop faim qui a des stats
aussi quoi et donc je pense que moi je
vais vous dire franchement j'ai fait des
sciences sociales pour arrêter de me
prendre la tête avec des maths même si
j'aimais bien les maths mais voilà après
je trouve que moi j'ai pas une formation
suffisamment poussées sur les stats on a
eu un cours de stats en première bac en
deuxième ce qu'on appelait camp dial est
à l'époque on a eu un cours d'analysé
des données mais vraiment on a un peu
utilisé spss c'était vraiment très
anecdotique j'ai envie de dire or les
enseignants peut-être ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts que c'est moi qui ai pas
compris toute la profondeur du court
mais moi j'en ai une profonde j'en
ressens une profonde car ans que
j'essaie de compenser aujourd'hui mais
c'est ça qui est intéressant aussi c'est
de lire ses articles et de voir les
outils statistiques qui vont être mis en
place et tu vas voir ici ça va être un
peu rock'n'roll si tu t'y connais pas
trop en sociaux à ses tons premier livre
de sociaux
désolé parce que tu as tu dois peut-être
avoir un rapport un peu vain voilà
encore un peu spécial ce bouquin la cua
mais c'est super si toi tu as
assez même le bouquin kita qui t'a
poussé dans ses études assez cool et
talus d'autres d'autres classiques sur
la méthodologie bon je parlais de
durkheim sur le suicide parce que bon
finalement c'est ça ça t'a plu aussi tu
les avais lui aussi avant tes études si
tu les as lu où
et quoi tu l'as lu kant est en terminale
alors comme ça
moi ça m'intéresse 1 comment parce que
je vais vous dire ce qu'on discute ici
ça va nourrir aussi mes cours
donc c'est super intéressant pour mon
mot vécu professionnel
parce que voilà après c'est de voir
qu'un cd exemple que je vais pouvoir de
nos élèves
[Musique]
c'est des récits de vie finalement parce
que c'est ce qu'on disait avec laurent
les jeunes jeudi les jeunes mais c'est
les ados un attentat 15 16 ans tu te
cherches et quand tu donnes des exemples
où si tu dis voilà je connais un élève
ou un étudiant qui a fait ceci qui a
fait cela un bouquin qui peut être une
révélation je trouve que c'est des
exemples qui sont tellement parlant
qu'on
sait c'est cool et quoi en terminale
c'est dans le cadre scolaire que tu l'as
lu
ouais les héritiers
c'est un peu austère les héritiers n'ont
quand tu le dis en terminale c et d des
bouquins tu avais lu dans le cadre de
terminale ou c'est des trucs que tu
avais lu à part parce que voilà tu avais
eu t1
comme on dit en s es
moi j'ai une fois un élève qui est venu
un examen de sciences sociales en
terminale fin en sixième à que les
héritiers jeu il fallait pas lire ça tu
voudrais demander je te ready des
bouquins beaucoup plus actuelle parce
que les héritiers c'est un peu datés
baissé mais les héritiers ça va encore
quoi je trouve que la reproduction est
beaucoup plus arides et austère
pour moi l'objectif du professeur de
secondaire tu me laurent et de donner
des outils aux élèves pour qu'ils
puissent réaliser eux mêmes leurs prises
de positions les plus objectif possible
tout à fait moi je suis vraiment sur le
même
sur la même longueur d'onde que toi et
moi j'ai même envie de dire et de leur
montrer ce qui existe aussi en termes de
débouchés en termes d'études c'est quoi
la géographie c'est quoi la sociologie
c'est quoi la psychologie ckoi
l'anthropologie de leur montrer c'est
quoi l'économie de leur montrer tout ça
et on s'en fout de finalement de ce
qu'ils étudient ou pas c'est pas ça
l'essentiel mais c'est qu'il trouve
quelque chose quoi quelque chose qui les
intéresse
finalement
effectivement ne pas oublier de
présenter les biais et de bien affirmé
que nous n'avons pas la science infuse
mais oui revenons aux moutons
en espèce on a parlé de sociaux donc
j'ai commencé à lire mais j'aime aussi
la philo donc j'ai regardé waeber super
c mois s'écoulent les gens comme toi les
les jeunes qui qui trouve un petit peu
leur truc comme ça à vienne lecture moi
je trouve ça tout ça beau vraiment
j'ai pensé à un truc aussi away la philo
mais alors quand tu vois durkheim
durkheim il a d'abord fait des études en
philo quand tu vois bourdieu il a fait
la file au pain est ce que tu peux assez
rarement être un bon chercheur ou un bon
élève ou un bon étudiant en sciences
sociales si t'as pas une fibre un peu
filou en toi je m'explique même dans le
programme de sciences sociales en
belgique on dit dans l'introduction
voilà la philosophie c'est une
excellente porte d'entrée pour le
questionnement et si t'as pas ce côté de
te poser des question du pourquoi du
comment qui est foncièrement l'objet de
la philosophie
est ce que tu peux après aller chercher
des comment dire des éléments empirique
pour répondre à ces questions là est-ce
que tu as la motivation pour le faire
voilà donc moi je pense que la philo est
profondément associé à la sociologie en
tout cas les deux sont vraiment très
très compatibles
et je vais même te dire que ici je me
suis fait une grosse commande alors
j'étais à la bibliothèque comme j'ai dû
tout à l'heure et à la librairie tout à
l'heure cet après midi mais j'ai passé
aussi une commande chez amazon parce que
j'ai pas trouvé tout ce que je cherchais
sur
dans la halle berry et j'ai commandé je
crois oui bouquin de philosophie
politique mais les classiques tu vois
hobbes montesquieu platon aristote tous
les classiques qu'on trouve gratuitement
sur le net en pdf mais j'avais vraiment
envie de les avoir dans ma bibliothèque
en format papier pour pouvoir aller
chercher vite vite quand je me dis ah
tiens au brésil n'a pas pensé ça hop est
allé chercher ses bouquins de
philosophie politique parce que
finalement tous ces mecs là avec le peu
de moyens qu'ils avaient à l'époque
jeudi en termes de connaissances
évidemment ils t'ont formule est parfois
mais des théories super moderne
quand tu vois le mouvement antivaccin
avec cette justification de la liberté
mais tu as juste envie le relire quand
je dis ça ça fait un petit peu celui qui
veut combattre les anti vaccins après
c'est pas du tout mon but chacun pense
ce qu'il veut mais je veux dire voilà tu
devrais lire un flamand des passages de
ops qui t'expliquent très bien comment
ta liberté bacula tu là confie en
quelque sorte à l'état pour qu'il assure
lui même sa sécurité est ce qu'on
appelle le contrat social quoi c'est une
évidence mais hobbes il écrit ça au 16e
siècle waouh cinq siècles plus tard on
est toujours au même point quoi moi je
trouve ça je trouve ça génial quand tu
as des des auteurs qui ont des
intuitions
philosophe donc c'est des philosophes
qui ont des intuitions et puis qu'après
tu utilises toujours ses intuitions la
500 ans plus tard moi je suis un grand
lecteur j'ai une grande passion j'ai
parti le bouquin aujourd'hui mais en
fait j'ai acheté le dernier
le dernier volume
de la collection spinoza chez garnier
flammarion voilà je suis un grand fan de
baruch spinoza
vraiment vraiment l'etics le bouquin que
je ne veux pas si on devait me dire
choisi un bouquin pour hull pour aller
sur une île déserte je prends les tic je
prends l'éthique de spinoza ça c'est sûr
c'est un bouquin je crois que j'aurais
jamais assez de divine que pour
l'épuiser ce bouquin mais voilà pour te
dire que la philosophie je pense que
c'est profondément corrélée avec les
sciences sociales et ne dit-on pas que
spinoza est un peu le père des sciences
sociales donc voilà après il ya des
peut-être des philosophes qui sont plus
compatibles avec les sciences sociales
que d'autres ça c'est peut-être sur quoi
laurent tu nous dis je remarque que chez
les élèves qu'ils ont de plus en plus de
mal à se poser les bonnes questions lors
de leur développement en sciences
sociales quoi pourquoi comment ouais
mais bon on est là pour ça quoi
ouais c'est fascinant hobbes et alors je
te dire
requins
j'ai suivi des séminaires de philo avec
une prof et alors elle était spécialiste
de hobbes mon à lui spinoza et qu'elle
met alors elle parlait tout le temps de
loeb est en fait voyelles m'a vraiment
mis alors sans mauvais jeu de mots une
obsession pour rob
et donc je n'ai jamais lu mais je vais
le dire quoi c'est pour ça que j'ai
commandé j'ai lu si je vais dire j'ai lu
des extraits sur tout va sur le pdf toit
du site que tu connais sans doute les
classiques des sciences sociales ce site
là il est formidable quoi tu as tous les
pdf que tu veux de tous les auteurs
classiques donc c'est super sympa
de lire obs'
mais voilà j'ai envie d'avoir le bouquin
de vraiment lire ça à tête reposée
tranquillement de souligner j'adore
faire ce à quoi
tu corriges des bilans mais c'est bien
ouais kern kern c'est formidable c'est
formidable ce que tu peux avoir avec cet
outil là quoi c'est ce que je dis
parfois aux élèves j'y mets rendez vous
compte kern enfin internet ça à 20 ans
moi je me souviens la première fois que
j'étais sur internet c'est peut-être en
98-99 mai imagine comment tu faisais
avant il fallait en biotech moi je me
souviens bibliothèque tu avais toutes
les revues scientifiques bombe en plus
des ouvrages voilà il fallait chercher
le numéro et tout ça tu avais pas de
moteur de recherche comme maintenant fin
il y en avait mais il n'était pas très
performant maintenant boom tarifs sur
kairn tu as directement site à l'accès
et à directement l'accès même à des
ouvrages complets celui-ci ce bouquin si
j'en aurais parlé pourtant j'ai pas de
deux commissions ni de lien affilié vous
inquiétez pas je ne me fais pas de fric
sur votre dos aujourd'hui c'est quand
vous regardez les vidéos youtube il ya
une petite rémunération mais vous
inquiétez pas être très faible mais bon
voilà suis ici je le monte parce que je
les sous la main mais celui-ci je crois
qu'il est en libre accès sur kairn
bauxite à des accès via fac
ben voila tu as ce bouquin si
libres d'accès enfin je veux dire si
c'est utile mais qui sont formidables
alors alors on va quand même revenir à
notre article il est 22h40 après j'ai
encore un stream à faire sur le
programme de mba enfin bon c'est
peut-être moins important que ça ici et
puis bon
je peux je peux faire ça plus tard n'y a
pas de souci mais revenons comme hamas a
donc on est sûr de l'analyse multivariée
et l'analyse des motifs s'est faite en
deux temps une classification ascendante
hiérarchique méthodes de ward alors là
je suis incapable de te dire ce que
c'est sans doute que la méthode de ward
renvoie un article de statistiques qui
est en lui même formulée en anglais
alors moi je vais pas jusque là j'ai pas
l'énergie ni le temps que pour tous
remontés donc ça voilà je suis
incompétent pour vous préciser sa
aboutissant à retenir cinq classes
distinctes a été réalisée chaque classe
ensuite fait l'objet d'une modélisation
par régression logistique binaire de
manière à identifier les variables
indépendantes significativement associée
à la probabilité d'appartenance de à la
quasi considérez donc tu vois là ça
s'accélère pour une régression
logistique c'est généralement ce que tu
fais entre une variable qualitative est
une variable quantitatif ou peut-être
même deux variables qualitative en fait
tu veux obtenir un indice qui va te
donner le niveau de lien entre ces deux
variables moi je dis souvent aux élèves
vous savez de soi sont les stats nu en
sciences sociales on les utilise après
savoir comment le logiciel les calculs
c'est pas notre notre objectif donc
voilà peu importe comment c'est calculé
mais simplement faut savoir que ça te
permet d'évaluer le lien entre les
variables
je pense que les élèves cherchent à
poser un jugement un avis une affiche
sur un sujet type pour avoir une valeur
de départ
je ne suis pas requins
je sais pas si tu peux
je vois pas quoi c'est quand tu fais
référence désolé
donc voilà donc ça c'est comment ils
vont faire et tu vois c'est ce que je
dis souvent dans une recherche qui veut
bien faire ta recherche tu es obligé
d'annoncer la couleur comment tu vas
traité alors en secondaire les élèves
souvent l'erreur qu'ils font ils font un
questionnaire mais savent pas du tout ce
qu'ils attendent donc tu dois savoir
pourquoi tu fais le questionnaire et tu
dois savoir le type de résultat auquel
tu dois arriver si tu veux que les
hypothèses soit vérifiée bien sûr après
tu peux arriver sur d'autres résultats
mais ça voudra dire que ces hypothèses
ne sont pas vérifiées mais tu dois déjà
connaître ça donc ici ils savent déjà
comment ils vont faire quoi
en tout cas tu dois le présenter comme
ça dans ton article
donc ici on nous donne quelques
statistiques descriptives c'est mes
souvenirs sont bons
[Musique]
alors le premier premier constat qu'ils
font sur la première partie du
questionnaire et la quasi-absence de
terminologie du décrochage dans le
discours donc il ya que oui réponse
cc c'est très peu oui réponses sur les
deux 1946 où l'élève il dit voilà je
suis dans une situation de décrochage
les personnes concernées ne se creuse
n'est ce pas spontanément dans la
catégorie institutionnel qui leur est
attribuée plusieurs hypothèses la
première est celle de l'expérience d'une
situation véhicule comme singulière
ouais il s'assimile pas finalement une
catégorie à la catégorie des décrocheurs
et qui ne peut être réduite à une
catégorie générale toutefois de
fréquentes réponse ne comporte pas ces
éléments singuliers nombreux sont au
contraire celles qui expriment une
lassitude générale de l'école en fait
ils en ont juste marre de l'école quoi
une deuxième hypothèse doivent donc être
envisagée celle de la connotation jugé
négatif de l'expression décrochage
scolaire tu vas pas te coller toi même
l'étiquette de décrocheurs scolaires
étant donné que c'est une étiquette
péjoratif ou négative
par contre il ya une fréquence de
discours négatifs dans leur réponse les
gemmes pas l'école ce n'est pas fait
pour moi je n'étais pas à ma place je ne
pouvais pas écouter les courses était
impossible j'ai arrêté voilà et sur les
six registre qu'on avait identifié trois
se réfère clairement des ressources
attendues pour la réussite scolaire donc
la disposition motivation capacités
c'est ce qui nous rappellent
ils expriment donc des manques d'une ou
plusieurs de ces trois ressources
alors c'est ce qu'on disait tantôt la
différence entre disposition et
les compétences ou c'était capacité
pardon
on va nous le dire ici à l'école c'est
pas ce qui m'intéresse donc en fait j'ai
pas la disposition pour suivre l'école
ils sont 34% c'est le plus non plus
nombreux ceux qui préfèrent la pratique
à la théorie on l'entend souvent en tout
cas il ya des élèves qui disent web la
théorie ça m'intéresse pas
33 9% c'est la motivation attention un
truc que j'ai pas précisé c'est que tu
as des les catégories peuvent se
chevaucher donc tu pourrais avoir un
élève qui dit voilà je suis par rapport
à ma disposition pas fait pour l'école
mais aussi je suis pas motivé donc tu
peux avoir en fait plus de 100 % au
total puisque tu peux retrouver un élève
dans plusieurs catégories
capacité 13%
donc là il sait des élèves qui vont
légitimité leur légitime et pardon leur
décrochage scolaire comme une incapacité
à atteindre un niveau attendu
le rejet ils sont relativement peu par
rapport aux autres catégories 10 % sont
dans du rejet
23%
sont dans un rapport d'attirance au
monde du travail des problèmes
personnels tu vois c'est aussi assez peu
12 6% ce que ce qu'il faudrait faire je
trouve alors c'est un truc je pourrais
faire c'est quand à une situation de
décrochage c'est l'interprétation qu'on
donne les profs est-ce que la
représentation qu'on l'épreuve du
décrochage
est conforme
à ce qui est dit dans cette enquête si
ce que j'ai l'impression parfois on
associe le décrochage simplement à des
problèmes personnels et du coup ça
empêche d'avoir une réflexion systémique
sur ce décrochage
bonjour prof le nain sur le chat de
twitch mais tu es polyvalent à mourir
dit donc
bah pour moi c'est pas non plus un bon
moins cinq jours les deux mais ce qui
est sympa c'est que tout le monde voit
tes interventions du coup
alors sur la vie d'un prof que tu
m'avais demandé à oui pardon
jeu désolé rend les élèves savent bien
que j'adore partir dans tous les sens je
ne m'empêche pas des digressions donc je
pense que les élèves cherchent à poser
un jugement un avis une affiche sur un
sujet type pour avoir une valeur de
départ où et c'est ça une sorte de de
repères de se caler sur
des trucs de savoir où on se positionne
et en fait c'est des bornes qui vont
avoir
finalement qu'est-ce que mais simplement
sur sur des clivages déjà politique
gauche droite tout ça c'est des élèves
sur les dépasse mais parfois ils ont un
intérêt pour savoir c'est quoi la gauche
c'est que la droite et dès que on aborde
les questions politiques en classe parce
que moi j'ai une séquence là dessus
c'est un et vous monsieur vous êtes tous
ben moi je vais pas te le dire quoi même
voilà à la gauche des textes explique
parce qu'ils ont besoin de points de
repère finalement c'est sûr
comme nous tous j'ai envie de dire
oui c'est ça tu vois laurent c'est ça je
trouve l'intérêt d'un article comme
celui ci mais déjà pour nous déjà pour
nous tu vas voir après il ya une
catégorie qui est super intéressante
c'est les décrocheurs discret et on y
reviendra parce que là ils sont plutôt
sur les motifs mais ils n'ont pas encore
fait leur typologie
alors davantage à des points de rupture
que la continuité d'une expérience
manques tu vois d'une manière générale
ces derniers motif se rapportent
davantage à des points de rupture
alors qu'on le décrochage c'est quasi
ses anticipe à bhl quelque part si c'est
un processus continu mais si on aborde
les choses en terme de de rupture il
s'est passé un truc élèves décrochent
mais j'ai envie de dire je sais pas ce
que tu en penses laurent je vais pas
aussi regret aucun tu peux aussi
peut-être
avoir un avis là dessus c'est le le le
fait qu'on attribue souvent à la crise
sanitaire des décrochages scolaires ou
des abandons scolaires finalement on en
revient toujours à un événement qui
serait un déclencheur alors que voilà je
pense qu'un élève qui était bien dans sa
scolarité bien dans ses études alors
c'est intéressant cité en première
l 1
ça serait intéressant d'avoir d'avoir
ton avis requin est ce que tu penses que
voilà est-ce que le la crise sanitaire a
vraiment été un déclencheur moi je pense
plutôt que la crise sanitaire a accéléré
a été un exhausteur 1 comme on dit en
séance un catalyseur de décrochage
scolaire ou d'arrêt d'études supérieures
puisque on ne parlera pas de décrochage
scolaire dans ce cadre là et donc c'est
toujours à ramener le décrochage
scolaire sur sur une rupture et non sur
un processus parce que qui dit requis du
processus dit à ce moment la réponse qui
peut être aussi réponse systémique
réponse de l'institution réponse du
corps professoral réponse des structures
annexes à l'école
ici là je les élève lui il est indiqué
on est sur des élèves du secondaire donc
ils ont 16 ans je pense
voilà c'est ici les élèves âgés de plus
de 16 ans le jour de l'observation qui
ont été classés en n1 donc voilà c'est
des élèves de cet âge la faim qui sont
en situation de décrochage scolaire
alors je les ai pas dit il se base sur
les données ministérielles
c'est une base de données officielle et
donc ils ont vraiment été piochés au
hasard
les
les uns les interviewer
et donc voilà quoi c'est un public du
secondaire
voilà on en était là je pense problèmes
personnels voilà autrement dit
alors
certains motifs proposés font l'objet
d'un accord très important un là on est
sur la deuxième partie de l'anc r
l'enquète où on demande aux élèves de se
positionner via une échelle de likert qu
sûr je sais plus combien dit m il y
avait une vingtaine dit m 24 je ne sais
plus exactement combien et donc j'en
avais marre de l'école 65% on en marre
de l'école en tant que tel
mais moi c'est ce que je ressens chez
tous les élèves je sais pas si tu es
d'accord laurent mais j'ai l'impression
que il ya vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
d'élèves alors c'est une impression
encore une fois mais qui en ont
simplement marre de l'école
beaucoup trop souvent même au niveau
ministériel on attribue très souvent
depuis deux ans le décrochage ou l'échec
à la crise sanitaire c'est une réponse
facile et je trouve qu'elle est bien
pratique pour passer sous silence
d'autres causes exactement c'est
exactement ça et et on voit l'utilité
des sciences sociales c'est un petit peu
de de remuer un petit peu la vase et que
les choses qu'on n'a pas envie de voir
remonte du tréfonds du verre quoi
ah ouais les étudiants c'est eux qui ont
été impactés en terme de réussite
scolaire et les lycéens ont
majoritairement réussi en tout cas nous
en belgique on a eu des consignes très
claires pour que voilà ça soit vraiment
exceptionnel qui est du redoublement
donc peut-être qu'en france c'est le
même principe mais en tout cas voilà moi
je trouve qu'il y avait des malaises
antérieures qui ont juste été révélées
par la crise sanitaire
et que du coup comme le dit laurent bas
c'est un peu facile de dire que c'est la
faute du coc vite hein mais c'est pas
que les élèves un qui dit ça où les
parents c'est aussi les enseignants
les politiques tout le monde tu d'accord
avec toi l'ont
alors il nous révèle pardon je voulais
avoir une activité professionnelle quand
même 67% sont attirés par le monde
professionnel
c'est quand même beaucoup je voulais
gagner de l'argent 61%
de son il ya une lassitude ça c'est un
fait dans le public des décrocheurs donc
les décrocheurs sont pas des gens qui
forcément
voilà son difficulté scolaire et ont
besoin d'une remédiation aussi parce qu
on voit ça souvent
le décrocheur à qu'est ce qu'on va
mettre en place on va lui mettre en
place la plateforme numérique pour
qu'ils puissent suivre les cours à
distance m'arrête marc est il en a marre
de l'école et tu vas lui remettre une
couche d'école sur son mal être et sur
sa lassitude générale quoi faut
réfléchir autrement
il nous révèle également l'attrait que
représente le marché du travail pour ces
jeunes on connaît pourtant les
difficultés d'insertion auxquels font
face les jeunes les moins qualifiés et
là c'est un paradoxe ils sont attirés
par le monde professionnellement
quittant l'école prématurément ils vont
avoir plus de difficultés sur le monde
professionnel puisqu'ils n'ont aucune
qualification
elles sont confirmées par l' enquête ou
seulement 29% des personnes interrogées
sont en emploi donc ils sont
67% à vouloir avoir une activité
professionnelle mais finalement ils sont
à 29% occupé professionnellement bon
après dans cela il ya sans doute aussi
des jeunes qui voient là ne sont pas
dans une situation professionnelle qui
l'aurait souhaité peut-être on peut
faire l'hypothèse a vérifié évidemment
donc c'est aussi intéressant parce que
tu as du décrochage scolaire m'apprête à
du mal être tu as du mal être après tu
t'étonnes d'avoir des crises sociales
comme les gilets jaunes mais attends je
veux dire tu à côté de ces jeunes voilà
qui sont qui sont peut-être en
situations de mal être parce que voyez
vous voulez travailler ils trouvent pas
les débouchés tu rajoutes d'autres
crises relater une cocotte minute
cet attrait pour le marché du travail
pourrait manifester un sentiment
d'inutilité de l'école pour accéder à
l'emploi
alors ça c'est pour moi le truc le plus
intéressant de la recherche c'est
l'établissement grâce aux différentes
applications qui l'ont opéré
statistiquement à cinq classes
contrastées
dont 3 laisse une large place à
l'attrait du marché du travail donc ça
c'est vraiment des typologies finalement
d idéal type 1 pour reprendre les mots
de weber
qu'ils vont établir et pour moi là on a
vraiment la création de choses qui
peuvent être utilisables pour la
réflexion et c'est ce à quoi je voulais
venir laurent quand j'utilisais qui est
à avoir une catégorie super intéressante
alors ce sont ces décrocheurs discret en
référence à la classification de jeanne
2 pour désigner des élèves qui bien que
rencontrant des difficultés scolaires se
conforment fortement aux normes
scolaires donc ils sont en situation
d'être immergé submergé par l'école mais
il croit toujours dans l'école donc il
essaie toujours quoi ils sont persuadés
de l'intérêt des apprentissages
scolaires mais ils ont été finalement
puisque c'est quand même le public de
l'enquète ils sont en situation de
décrochage scolaire donc on a quand même
une part tu vois ici 27 % de
l'échantillon une part des élèves qui
dévalorise pas l'école
et cela c'est cela qu'on doit aider par
des remédiations par des des comment
dire des mesures de soutien scolaire à
proprement parler quoi vraiment du
coaching scolaire à limites parce que
voilà ils y croient ils sont pas en
rejet par rapport à l'école donc tu vois
là là il ya c'est ce que je dis souvent
élèves les sciences sociales ça permet
d'identifier les causes si tu as mal au
ventre il peut y avoir plein de causes
différentes mais voilà peut-être que
manger ça va juste résoudre ton mal au
ventre c'était juste tu avais un peu
faim mais voilà tu vas pas manger
systématiquement dès que tu as mal au
ventre parce qu'il ya d'autres causes
donc tu risque de faire pire que mieux
si c'est l'indigestion tueur manche
dessus
voilà tu vas cause yves jeu pastis que
je dirais très pertinent au niveau
médical mais c'est l'image quoi est donc
ici pour ces élèves là il faut les
identifier dans le système scolaire
parce que cela il faut les coacher en
fait je pense les jeunes évoquent plus
souvent que dans les autres classes une
formation non choisi mauvaise
orientation voilà une autre cause des
problèmes personnels alors là c'est
plutôt l'intervenant extra scolaires qui
doit qui doit agir le le centre psycho
médico social en belgique j'ai pas en
france comment ça s'appelle la médecine
scolaire quoi et la peur de l'échec 26%
donc là on revient sur des gens qui
doivent être coaché pour être rassurés
ces décrocheurs ce que discrets sont
quasiment unanimes pour rejeter la
proposition je ne voyais pas l'utilité
de ce que j'apprenais à l'école donc
dans le décrochage scolaire tapas que
qu'un seul type de public puisque tu as
un public qui a encore en loyauté par
rapport à l'école et puis à côté de ça
évidemment tu te doutes bien qu'il ya
ceux qui sont en rejet de l'institution
scolaire à 14 % mais qui sont largement
minoritaires ils sont moitié moins que
ceux qui sont en décrochage discret
c'est la moitié
ils sont 55 2 d'accord avec l'item je
n'ai pas eu de l'orientation que je
souhaitais donc cette idée d'orientation
marche toujours
après est-ce que c'est un problème
d'information donc là on a une
problématique de mimizan connaissance
des différentes orientations et là tu
vois directement le lien que tu peux
faire avec ce que j'ai dit en début de
stream quant à les classes populaires
qui finalement n'ont pas une bonne
vision des différentes filières possible
et des choses comme ça et donc après tu
tu dois pas t'étonner de retrouver plus
les classes populaires sur représentés
dans les non qualifications puisque
finalement c'est elle qui se retrouve
dans ces catégories là d'ailleurs on le
verra plus tard ou pas je ne sais plus
si on le voit d'ailleurs
ça c'est super intéressant
aussi ce qui est intéressant j'ai
souligné les méthodes d'enseignement ne
sont pas ici en cause les répondants
n'exprime pas de mésentente avec des
enseignants donc c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus générale c'est du
désengagement scolaire ça c'est la
troisième partie c'est ce qui se
désengage de l'école
déception sur le contenu de la formation
et qui ont sans doute un projet
alternatif
le quatrième groupe représente 24% de
l'échantillon
est là c'est les travailleurs quoi ils
veulent travailler d'abord jobs jobs
comme dirait l'autre
effectivement
les élèves en ont marre de l'école je
trouve que même titre que nous
l'utilisation accrue de l'informatique
amen si on ne met pas soi même des
limites une vers 2 qui serait encore
pire pour les décrocheurs oui c'est ça
tu veux rajouter des bus scolaires en
tout cas pour ça dépend le type de
décrocheurs c'est une question de bon
diagnostic cas par cas qui permettrait
d'aider correctement les différents
types de décrocheurs oui cas par cas
mais on est bien d'accord en mobilisant
peut-être des connaissances comme celle
ci pour avoir une typologie en tête et
pas se dire finalement d'arriver dans un
atome isme on se dit finalement chaque
cas est particulier et finalement on ne
sait pas avoir en considérant que chaque
cas est particulier dans sa part avoir
une action globale quelque part c'est un
peu ce qu'on avait eue dans l'école dans
mon école qui est la tienne aussi en
l'occurrence
sur pourquoi les élèves ne seraient rien
ce qui vais pas et on n'avait pas fait
un bon travail d analyse des données qui
n'avait pas abouti à une typologie et
finalement le l'enquète a été classée
sans suite parce qu'on s'est dit ob il
ya tellement de motifs différents que
finalement c'est pas agir non mais tu
doit regrouper en utilisant des outils
comme celui-ci quoi oui c'est ça ben moi
sa moc et ça m'inquiète aussi tu sais
c'est sûr
donc jo jokes et puis une dernière
classe e c'est ben c'est une classe un
peu fourre-tout c'est un nombre
important de motifs mais finalement
c'est cette recette
et cette classe est appelée problèmes
personnels parce qu'en fait ils ont des
problèmes surtout extérieurs à l'école
donc il ya une analyse multivariée qui
est fait à partir de ces typologies
pourvoir sur cette construction
quels types d'élèves en termes
sociologiques on retrouve dans quelle
catégorie
donc ça c'est super intéressant je vais
pas tout lire ici parce que on a le
tableau est donc tu vois après ils ont
fait une régression logistique on s'en
fout un peu de ce que c'est l'important
c'est de savoir que quand tu es en
dessous de 1 c'est sous représentés et
quand tu es au dessus de 1 c'est sûr
représentée alors bain par exemple tu
vois que dans le désengagement scolaire
les garçons sont sur représentés sur
représentés pourquoi sans doute parce
que tu as des effets de
socialisation genre et qui fait que le
garçon on va accepter de sa part dans sa
socialisation primaire beaucoup de
turbulences où là c'est normal d'être
turbulent canadien qu'on a un garçon ait
commencé que il ya un métier d'élève qui
nécessite une certaine tenue de son
comportement un certain fait de pouvoir
rester ainsi de ne pas s'exprimer à tord
et à travers les garçons du coup sont
pénalisés et se désengage du scolaire
parce que voilà il se trouve c'est pas
fait pour moi ben oui c'est pas fait
pour toi puisque tu es un garçon si tu
veux donc c'est un peu une justification
dans ce type là qu'on peut reprendre des
problèmes personnels ben voilà ils sont
sous représentés en effet parce que déjà
les garçons ne parlent pas de leurs
problèmes personnels de ces mêmes ici
peut-être même qu'il ya un biais au
niveau de la mesure dans le sens où les
garçons peut-être sous déclarent des
problèmes personnels parce que voilà un
garçon ça doit être fort et
ça doit supporter les petits les petits
aléas du quotidien
il nous faut des grilles d'analysé un
support qui permettrait de prendre en
compte les récurrences oui bah ça c'est
clair que c'est pas nous qui allons
faire ça ici on ne fait que du blabla
laurent
c'est clair qu'il faudrait mais il
faudrait en fait d'une politique
publique de détection du décrochage
scolaire quoi l'identifier déjà des
indicateurs observable dans le
comportement des élèves qui permettrait
aux enseignants de remonter des
situations de pouvoir après avoir des
mesures des plans d'action en fonction
de la typologie dans laquelle seraient
l'élève voilà quoi c'est pas nous avec
nos temps de classe qui pouvons gérer ce
à quoi ou même le temps de conseils de
classe qui est vraiment réduit
c'est vrai c'est un décrochage c'est un
truc que tu as travaillé
c'est ça c'est le décrochage
alors tu vois aussi que les agriculteurs
artisans commerçants chefs d'entreprise
sont enlisés des engagements mais c'est
un petit peu l'exemple que je prenais
tout à l'heure avec le fils de mon
garagiste voilà quand à des parents qui
sont dans un dans une activité très
prenante comme elle est celle d'un
agriculteur
le nombre d'enfants d'agriculteurs qui
n'ont qu'un seul objectif saleh sur le
tracteur avec leur papa ou avec leur
maman pourquoi pas
voile à l'école ça paraît fade à côté je
pense et donc c'est normal que tu es
finalement du désengagement chez eux bon
chef d'entreprise voilà que tu vois ton
père ou alors ça peut être à linverse
ton père qui est chef d'une grande
entreprise où il ya des moyens tu sais
quasi intuitivement que tu vas reprendre
la sphère familiale si c'est une
histoire familiale donc voilà l'école ça
te semble un peu chiant par rapport aux
enjeux
qui peuvent être autres mais bon il
faudrait que ça corresponde avec
travailler d'abord et tu vois que
travailler d'abord là ça contredit donc
peut-être que je fais la
surinterprétation ici parce que tu vois
qu'ils sont sous représentées chez les
travailler d'abord donc je dis peut-être
une bêtise alors les employés sont
surreprésentés dans les problèmes
personnels pourquoi
difficile à dire
j'ai vraiment noté que les gros écarts
quoi ici tu pourrais dire travailler
d'abord à bâtir trou chez les
agriculteurs mais quand c'est la
profession de la mer pas quand c'est la
profession du père tu vois il ya un
delta la
annonce jeudi je dis n'importe quoi je
commence à fatiguer on est à 0 7 donc
non c'est cohérent pardon autant pour
moi là je fais une analyse de bain
le redoublement de le rendre lorsque la
scolarité à ce que ça a joué un moment
sur leur décrochage scolaire tu pourrais
dire que oui ban on regarde ça dépend du
type de décrocheurs votre ça c'est super
intéressant et sur certains certaines
typologies t quasi proche de 1 donc ça
veut dire que ça n'a aucun effet ici
voilà là ça joue un petit peu sur le
rejet de l'institution scolaire un petit
peu sur les problèmes personnels voilà
un décrochage scolaire qui arrivent mais
tu vois que c'est pas si déterminant
qu'on pourrait le penser sur base de nos
représentations
voilà et puis après tout où ils en sont
dans leur
dans leur parcours scolaire et puis
après évidemment à ce qu'il séchait les
cours durant sa dernière formation tu
vois que ça joue sauf pour ici ça joue
très peu évidemment pour les élèves en
décrochage discret donc tu peux avoir en
classe des élèves qui sont super
studieux mais qui sont en décrochage
waouh
wac et nous et il passe je suis sûr
qu'ils passent par je suis sûr on n'est
jamais sûr de rien mais voilà c'est une
intuition ce serait vraiment tragique
qui passent à travers les radars et il
passe un trader
alors est-ce qu'il travaillait
régulièrement battus voit ceci travail
relativement régulièrement quoi par
contre évidemment citer en opposition
par rapport à la chose scolaire l'attend
étaient sur représentés
voilà donc tu vois c'est super
intéressant ce genre de régression parce
que évidemment ça occulte on généralise
certaines certaines choses on rassemble
parfois des choses très différentes ou
relativement différente aurait plutôt le
dire comme ça mais c'est super
intéressant quant à la chine comme ça tu
vois directement
selon ces indicateurs ou où il ya des
choses qui sont significatives alors une
faible assiduité au travail voilà il
interprète les résultats donc la
conclusion pour conclure
retenons tout d'abord que les jeunes en
rupture scolaire ne se reconnaissent pas
spontanément dans la désignation de
décrocheurs alors les amis on va faire
une sensibilisation au décrochage
scolaire mais ici ce dernier fit pas à
ça donc tu vois par exemple on parlait
de mesures que vous pouvez faire les
sciences sociales sont encore très
intéressante
finalement pour avoir une bonne action
par rapport à des problèmes de société
une sensibilisation ça marcherait pas il
faudrait d'abord fait une détection
leur expérience de la rupture scolaire
est vécue globalement sur le registre de
la diski disqualification notamment à
retire des catégories légitime du monde
scolaire
mais pour eux ces manques sont aussi
ceux de l'école ils ont un fort
ressentiment vis-à-vis de l'institution
scolaire mais de là à également se
construit une forte aspiration à la
valorisation dans le monde du travail
rémunéré pourtant celui-ci et peu
accueillant pour les jeunes est d'autant
moins que l'expérience scolaire qui a
précédé le coup de décrochage scolaire
était difficile bon ils se sont pas trop
foulé nos amis ici sur la conclusion
pardon
et il ya un truc je reviens sur un truc
je vais vous lire j'ai vais lire le ce
qui se passe dans le
à laurent tu mets des jurons il ya auto
le modérateur automatique kit à filtrer
un message allez je te le publie c'est
bien parce que c'est toi j'ai
l'impression qu'on peut faire un lien
avec le monde intériorisé durant la
socialisation primaire étant le plus
impactant pour l'individu et le monde
découvert durant la socialisation
secondaire où celle ci exige un
vocabulaire spécifique pour être membre
un individu n'est pas née membres il le
devient livre de bergueira luckman
encore un grand classique que j'ai pas
lu la construction fin des grands
auteurs que j'ai pas lu la construction
sociale de la réalité cette découverte
peut-elle expliquer un certain type de
décrochage ouais bah c'est sûr c'est
vraiment le décalage
n'a en fait en fait le problème de
l'école c'est le problème des implicite
c'est que l'école elle dit on va vous
évaluez sur des savoirs ou des savoir
faire ou des compétences savait pas où
on en est dans le développement de
l'école
mais en fait tu vas plus tôt ce que dit
bourdieu tu va évaluer une façon d'être
tu va sélectionner des gens qui sont
conformes par rapport à leur façon
d'être et la façon d'être tu l'as kirk
ans ben voilà donc associer ses
alisation un tu deviens bons élèves qui
le devient comme en mai par la
socialisation alors tu peux le faire en
classe mais évidemment si dans son
milieu familial il ya un modèle
totalement opposé au rôle qu'ils sont
attendus dans le milieu scolaire il va y
avoir en fait un double mouvement qui
doit être fait et c'est assez violent
parce que c'est un mouvement
acculturation tu doit effacer quelque
part ta culture familiale est
généralement notre culture familiale où
l'un à l'intérieur ça fait partie de
notre identité donc c'est super violent
parce que tu dois changer d'identité
donc tu doit effacer ça renier un petit
peu le monde auquel tu appartiens
pour après apprendre un nouveau rôle de
nouveaux codes de nouvelles normes aux
nouvelles habitudes donc tu as un double
mouvement et ça c'est pas dit dans le
cursus scolaire on ne te dis pas voilà
on va vous évaluez sur votre façon
d'être mais on évalue sur la façon
d'être et d'autant plus dans certains
types d'enseignement bourdieu disait que
alors je vais je vais déformé ses
paroles je suis désolé il disait un
examen oral par exemple c'est un examen
de des trous face à un examen
d'apparence en fait on s'en fout du
compte du contenu dans un examen oral
mais l'école passe son temps à évaluer
ça alors ça se retrouve parfois de
manière plus ou moins explicite dans des
notes de comportement
mais je crois que c'est des notes qui
disparaissent des bulletins des carnets
de notes et donc voilà ça va se
ressentir au cours et le prof qu'est ce
qu'il va dire à mes élèves voilà il m'a
répondu je lui ai mis une punition et il
n'a pas fait et tout ça mais en fait
voilà tu es tu es en train de de
sanctionner une appartenance sociale
voilà après moi un truc c'est un truc je
suis à fond dans toute l'explication de
bourdieu après peut-être que j'exagère
l'importance de ce facteur là mais
voilà quand tu lis quand tu lis quand tu
lis ces travaux là c'est ce que ça dit
donc je pense que c'est compatible avec
berg et luckman mais on prévoit là je
les ai pas lues donc je ne sais pas te
dire de manière précise si c'est
pertinent pas
alors laurent je me demande si ce genre
le décrochage s'exprime par le manque de
compréhension profonde de la matière je
remarque beaucoup d'élèves qui étudient
comme des fous mais ne cherchent pas à
comprendre mais plutôt à restituer
à part dont laurent s'était pas toi
c'était le poste de requins qui avait
été bloqué par
mode mais je sais pas où le modérateur
automatique a vu qu'il y avait un juron
lorsque tu mets ici dans ta réponse
requins que je viens de lire je vois pas
de ce qui aurait pu poser problème quand
faut pas se poser de questions c'est là
qu'on voit que les machines ne peuvent
pas tout
voilà je vaux je sais pas le beauf ou
peut-être je sais pas je me demande si
ce genre de décrochage ouais bon après
sur sur les élèves qui essaient de
restituer en fait je pense aussi quand
tu lis bourdieu que tout ce qu'on a fait
en termes de compétences tu n'as fait
l'interprète bourdieu un jeu que ce
bourdieu ce que ce qu'on a fait en
termes de compétences de dire aux élèves
voilà on va plus vous évaluez que ce que
sur des savoirs on va vous évaluer aussi
sur des compétences c'est en fait
favorisé un peu plus
les classes favorisées qui sont déjà
favorisés je m'explique ce qu'est ce
qu'une compétence c'est du savoir du
savoir faire et du savoir être tu peux
regarder la division dans le décret
missions de ce qu'est une compétence qui
doivent être mobilisés dans une tâche
complexe bonjour l'implicite quoi parce
que tu une enseigne jamais tout dans
cette compétence est donc en fait que
des élèves qui auront plus facilement la
compétence
que des élèves issus d'un milieu plus
modestes parce que les élèves d'un
milieu modeste tu vas leur donner une
liste de vocabulaire bas mais ils vont
étudier quoi voilà vocabulaire elle
était fille n'est pas étudiée donc je
pense que en fait un apprentissage qui
portent plus sûr de savoir va être plus
égalitaire et femmes - défavorisés ceux
qui sont déjà favorisés à l'entrée
voilà
mais voilà c'est clair que c'est un
confort pour les lèvres de restituer
c'est sûr maintenant comprendre on en
demande beaucoup à certains élèves je
dis bien certains élèves
après tu vois tu vas voir tu auras
certains élèves alors on va dire ah mais
il a de la culture parce que il a bien
formulé sa réponse parce qu'il a mis une
petite référence personnelle et donc on
va être un peu charmée par par cet élève
par son aisance au niveau verbal au
niveau de l'écrit mais finalement on
évalue parce qu'on a enseigné et c'est
le décalage aussi entre ce qui est
enseigné ce qui est évalué qui pose
problème quand je vois des élèves de 2e
de troisième alors pas forcément dans
l'école dans laquelle je travaille parce
que mes enfants sont dans une autre
école et ma femme travaille dans une
troisième école donc j'ai des exemples
d'école sous la main mais quand on
demande aux élèves voilà tu un cours sur
l' empire romain ou que sais je sur la
mythologie romaine voile a fait un
exposé sur artemis
l'élève oui voilà au niveau du contenu
vallée sur internet il va chercher mais
faire l'exposé ca priou parfois tu lis
les consignes et a même pas de consignes
donc qu'est-ce que tu fais pas tu
évalues les élèves qui viennent qui
viennent dans un milieu dans lesquels on
sait construire à la maison d exploser
ou dans lesquels à la maison on
travaille de manière tout à fait
implicite est tout à fait comment dire
naturel on travaille éloquence
autre exemple dans notre école il ya un
tournoi d'éloquence et puis certains
élèves sont vraiment très brillant et
félicitations à eux évidemment ils ont
travaillé pour et ils ont préparé un
texte qu'ils ont étudiés par coeur qu'il
restitue avec il restitue avec aisance
mais en fait on évalue encore une fois
quelque chose qui a été appris dans la
socialisation primaire qui a été appris
dans le contexte familial ou dans les
activités extrascolaires et donc l'école
évalue des choses qui se font en dehors
de l'école on en est là hein mais c'est
un truc que voilà bourdieu l'a 10 à 50
ans et on en est toujours là moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on est toujours là après
on n'est pas obligé d'être d'accord avec
ça et bien donc voilà petite
bibliographie
fall est assez courte de nos deux amis
de l'université de nantes samedi nos
deux amis mais je ne les connais pas du
tout je dis ça parce qu'on est en fin de
ce tri mais que voilà serait on commence
à être un peu fatigué aussi et on se
relâche je vous remercie en tout cas
pour votre participation surtout prof le
nain dit laurent où laurent plutôt 10
pro fenain et requins 91 je vous
remercie vraiment c'était très sympa
d'avoir un chat comme ça aussi actif
voilà ça me donne qu'une seule envie
c'est de continuer à faire c'est stream
si vous avez vraiment des thèmes qui
vous intéressent rendez vous sur youtube
alors on peut aller y aller ensemble ça
je vous montre un petit peu où ça se
passe
en termes de sondages où je choisis les
différents thèmes où je propose pardon
la sélection des différents thèmes on va
aller voir la société qui si vous êtes
cinq spectateurs en plus c'est bien
c'est bien donc je respecte aussi ceux
qui ne sont pas sur le chat je vous
salue ria pas de soucis vous n'êtes
vraiment pas obligés d'intervenir mais
je vous remercie aussi d'avoir d'avoir
écouté ce stream qui se termine a envoyé
dans l'onglet communauté je sais pas si
vous y allez souvent mais dans l'onglet
communauté je propose des sondages comme
ceci donc ça c'est le sondage d'il ya
deux semaines pour ce stream si vous
voyez que il y avait les droites
populistes radical en europe occidentale
donc là je propose les thèmes je vous
donne les liens sur les différentes
les différentes recherches mais si vous
avez d'autres recherches voilà que vous
aimeriez qu'on aborde n'hésitez pas à
vous la proposer en commentaire et je
regarde si c'est possible évidemment je
vais vous montrer déjà les choix de la
semaine prochaine c'est pas encore
publiés
et ici je vous ai mis directement dans
le poste les abstracts de telle sorte à
ce que voilà vous ayez vraiment une idée
de ceux de quoi ça va parler sans se
prendre la tête mais comme ça vous avez
une petite idée alors le premier article
ben voilà les élections présidentielles
approchent donc je mets systématiquement
un article plus politique
l'élysée lieux de décision donc là c'est
quelqu'un qui n'est pas je pense qu'elle
n'est pas chercheuse en sciences
sociales elle a plutôt une témoin direct
qui a participé à la vie dans les alizés
qui a fait une analyse de son
fonctionnement donc voilà si tu sais pas
c'est quoi à l'elysée ben c'est là où
réside le président de la république
mais surtout là où il travaille aussi
donc c'est comment la prise de décision
comment dire se formule dans cet espace
finalement donc c'est très intéressant
je pense un requin que c'est un petit
peu anthropologique comme approche
le deuxième recherche rechercher la race
les défis d'une enquête à mots couverts
donc là on va s'intéresser bassett à ce
terme qui est très polémique mais
comment voilà comment est ce qu'on le
dit dans certains milieux j'avoue que je
n'ai pas
je n'ai pas investiguer plus que ça j'ai
lu l'abstrait que ça m'avait dit tiens
c'est un thème qu'on n'a pas encore trop
trop investiguer l' enquête révèle que
la dc bilité de la race est une d'ici
midi thé à la fois complexes soumise à
conditions hétérogènes selon qu'il
s'agit de nommer des groupes
minoritaires ou le groupe majoritaire
un titre d'exemple mais quand tu as un
élève
blacks dans ta classe tu sais jamais
comment tu dois dire les mots si blake
c'est bien la javel une fois que blake
vaincu tu es vraiment dans une prise de
tête comment le dire à leur pareil pour
les personnes asiatiques ou voilà quand
tu as une origine ethnique comment est
ce que tu dis les choses sans paraître
voilà
ben voilà c'est des choses qui sont
difficiles à dire et donc ça me passe et
ça me paraissait intéressant et surtout
un peu percutant au niveau de l'objet
d'études
et le dernier migrations internationales
ce que l'on mesure est donc là c'est
assez intéressant parce que c'est une
analyse vraiment sur des statistiques
assez assez importante sur si vous voilà
sur l'évolution de la l'immigration
comme on regarde ça et comment on
travaille ça vous voyez pas encore de
vote parce que le sondage n'est pas
encore publiée il sera publié demain à
6h45 du matin donc voila vous aurez
l'occasion de voter jusque samedi pour
le thème qui vous intéresse et cette
fois ci je vous dis vraiment au revoir
je fais un petit tour sur le tchat
voilà je pense qu'il n'y a rien de
nouveau forcé honneur monsieur c'est
très agréable comme live et interactions
bas merci laurent et à plus tard dans
les écoles est ce qu'il y à une note
sur l'intuition
non il me semble pas mais en fait tu
l'évaluent à tulle évalue
autrement par voilà tout ce qui est déjà
tu vois notre sueur sur la maîtrise de
la langue
c'est sur le style parfois tu vois dans
des grilles d'évaluation le style alors
après je sais pas en france comment ça
ce pacs comment ça se passe en termes
d'évaluation mais tu dire tous toujours
et puis à des effets de halo qui joue
sur les lèves tu reconnais son écriture
il écrit bien donc voila tu va accorder
plus de temps sur la lecture de cette
copie là donc il ya plein de billets
aussi dans l'évaluation qui fait que
finalement
l'implicite et évaluer même si on dit
qu'il n'est pas évalué
et finalement même si c'est des
évaluations qualitatives donc juste du
feedback en termes de remarques mais ça
conditionne la scolarité de l'élève
parce que si tu fais du renforcement
positif ben voilà il va être tirée vers
par une valorisation de lui-même de sa
scolarité en même temps si tu fais
toujours du renforcement négatif bas à
ce moment là il va être tiré plutôt vers
le bas quoi donc ça se passe comme ça
bon ben voilà allez cette fois ci j'y
vais on se retrouve pour ce qu'ils sont
vraiment très très motivés par la
société
après je découvre je fais une petite
pause quand même boire un coup et tout
ça et on se retrouve sur twitch
uniquement pour discuter et analyser
ensemble programme d'eric zemmour donc
on va aller sur son site et voir un
petit peu quelles sont ces mesures
phares quoi voilà sans jugement de
valeur évidemment allez je vous salue et
je vous dis à bientôt prochain live sur
la présentation d'articles ce sera
dimanche je rappelle salut salut